by the hot tub place in Keene he's got a
stack of them sitting out front there
which seems like outrageous to me so so
yeah I I certainly uh support the con
you know think that we need to do more
you know they need you know they need to
get service but
all right so anybody have a problem with
retaining this bill
okay
so we'll
oh John you would like to see
you can wait wait till you take it up as
a full committee okay so the
recommendation at this point is to uh
to retain it
okay so does everybody understands what
retaining means we will have to vote on
the committee the world's committee will
have to vote to retain it uh in the old
days it used to be the chair could have
a sense of retaining and just I could do
the chair could unilaterally do that
then people decided that that wasn't
right that wasn't fair and so then they
changed the rule that we now that we do
actually have a vote we'll have a vote
to retain it
um and uh but that it actually we the
retaining motion does not go to the
floor it's just an automatic motion that
the committee retains it it just
automatically is retained and
um and then we would take up retain
bills next fall and uh retain bills then
have to be out of committee uh by end of
October and uh and the one one week not
that anyone's going to want to miss a
session day anyways but the one week you
don't want to miss it's the first week
in January because that's when all the
retain bills hit the floor and uh so and
now can be rather exciting
representative
just a question on procedure if the if
the prime sponsor comes to us with an
amendment before we vote to retain we
would consider that amendment is that
correct if a prime sponsor came forward
with an amendment before we vote to
retain it I mean even in remote to
retain it um I mean it's it's what's
this bill number this is 73.
so we don't have to we don't have to
take action on this until March by the
mid-march
to retain it so yes if an amendment
would if someone came forward with an
amendment
um I would certainly call another
subcommittee and then we would discuss
that amount but I wouldn't wait until
exact session so so yeah this is this uh
this is a late departure so with um the
person whoever the persons have have a
month to come up with something
yeah
it would still be the subcommittee
yeah what's up committee okay
okay
next up uh
uh 173 related to toilet facilities
provided by restaurants
so wasn't there
the uh someone from the home uh uh the
building code is Code Enforcement right
the code is that he he or she here today
no but they're recommended we just
repeal the whole statue is that is that
right yeah
foreign
okay
not in expedient this was to repeal
the RSA
is that if I got that right
but the codes aren't ready yet
but the code's not ready
what code was supposed to be ready the
state building codes the state building
code is still
it's still in development but eventually
we should repeal this eventually okay so
we just retain it would because we don't
know when that'll happen right so I
guess we should just retain it then
okay
you already okay with that retaining
what are we doing gonna retain it and
for what purpose uh we're waiting until
the new building uh State Building Code
gets implemented and in that time we
would then repeal this whole paragraph
okay
all right we remain along all right
um 178 relative to enforcement of condo
liens for assessments
um I I got a phone message from the
sponsor last night and he requests that
we retain this bill
um I had a long phone conversation with
him on Monday and we I basically said
you you need to if the issue is that the
the banks are not foreclosing then you
need to you need to work with them to
figure out a way to get them to
foreclose but I said I my sense was from
this committee that we were not too
excited about the idea of the neighbors
for closing on you simply because you
haven't paid your your fees but I don't
know how anybody else
see it any different than that
what's the point out one other issue
with the bill that wasn't discussed much
uh previously it also allows just
provides an adequate protection for
tenants that a number of condos are
leased out by owners who are not
actually
using the unit themselves this would
allow for tenants who are renting the
unit in good faith to potentially be
evicted despite paying their rent in
full who have nothing to do with the
condo fees and would then be displaced
because a an owner who doesn't like the
amount they're paying for a pool fee and
is withholding the the condo association
fee those tenants would then be
displaced through no fault of their own
we need to find a protection for good
faith tenants in the bill as well
John good luck with that well it may be
this is just sometimes there's a bill is
just a bad Bill
that too
Mr chair what was it supposed to be an
amendment that took that made this only
applicable to houses that have been
abandoned right that's true that was a
that was the uh Amendment they were
trying to work on but good luck on
defining that what's abandoned yeah
right you know Bandy says okay there's
no no no things in it but you know Steve
Jobs had was pretty sparse in his living
arrangements you know so you know you
might not have much in there and people
can say oh that looks abandoned to me
well you know just because the person
he's got a job overseas and and not
around but he's paying his mortgage or
he or she is paying their mortgage
they're paying their taxes the only
thing they're not paying is the
association fees and you know maybe they
think they don't have to pay it or
shouldn't have to pay it because they're
you know it's not right either I that is
true
but audience members yes okay
come on up Garrett yeah you don't come
up just speak from there and speak
loudly okay okay well actually you might
just speak my I'm sorry representative
Gibbs would like you to speak to the mic
I'm sorry
yep
I just wanted to provide a quick uh
update we actually had a brief
warning with the back this bill uh both
sides are willing to work on it both
sides are willing to meet to discuss it
and uh we do believe that if you retain
the bill and afford US the time that we
will be able to turn this into something
passable uh we believe that that there
certainly is a problem we are going to
attempt to resolve it in a way that
works for both sides and that's what we
hope to be able to present great
then of course and the bankers agree I
have a question
chairman you want to say you want to
speak to her okay okay
yes representative Herbert go ahead I
just uh an observation of if my memory
serves me correctly there was an issue
of how long uh uh you can go with the
lien uh it's not an immediate thing I
mean you there was a time frame was it
six months well the six months is in the
current law now
that was just that was where we already
passed over the six months but this was
this was that they you know if they had
if it how if it wasn't occupied for a
year or something it was some was there
a timeline on how long it wasn't
occupied yeah we're working to Define
that okay but it was that so that
amendment was never drawn up it yeah no
not yet
no so anyway so that wasn't actually
determined but that yes there was uh
some discussion about it and I and I I
was unclear as to what
what that was going to be because I
thought the time frame was was uh
important
stay tuned on that okay yeah go ahead
sorry
um thank you committee members uh yeah
we did have a brief conversation and we
would be open to at least looking at
what is proposed
um as long as it doesn't impact
um Banks property rights
um and obviously the foreclosing of
um of the unit by the Association is
always something that is very concerning
to us so but we are open to at least
looking at um some language to see if it
could address uh their concerns as well
as protect our property rights
so thank you great all right so yes okay
representative Gibbs and then obviously
cool thank you uh I just like to
reiterate that I think it's extremely
important that any Amendment
um provide protection uh for the condo
owner uh so that the condo owner would
not be foreclosed
um and evicted from a 200 000 unit for a
two thousand dollar
um unpaid condo fee because that's what
as As I understood it at least the bill
as presented was just
um uh six months
um and it didn't didn't change the the
six months unpaid condo fees uh and I
calculated that out just for my own unit
uh and it was a little over two thousand
dollars and I just wanted to reiterate
the importance of providing some
protection uh against that unfairness so
there's three things represent a call
thank you Mr chair I'd like Ryan to come
back up and talk about the risks the
bank has to take
no we don't we don't have to do it you
don't have to do that no no but we we
all hear you
because we're not taking tests when
we're not this is this is just a
subgrade
you can give your opinion that is true
you can give your opinion you can say
you think this is too risky for well I
would say this is absolutely too risky
for the bank yeah because you had
lawyers come up here and saying that we
can spend twenty thousand dollars in
Lori bills trying to chase these fees
and then the you sell the property on
the bank and the bank's the one that's
on the hook for the 30 grand
not the association you need to keep
that in mind folks
there you go okay
take that as instruction
okay so my instinct was right on that
one okay uh all right moving on relative
condo disclosure of financial
information so this is now
representative about me so
representative you do realize the cut
that this is not what uh accountants do
you come on up to the microphone
you have to turn you have to press the
you know yeah you know how to do this
so you you disagree you think
accountants will be would be willing to
do this well there I have spent quite a
lot of time in recent days talking with
the CCPA society and talking with on
several accountants that I know in my
town including the one that is doing
this for us and for a lot of small
non-profits in Lebanon area uh
and on but I do have a clearer I think
version of it as an amendment of what
that person does in Lebanon and what
other people when you
uh go down a Commercial Street in a town
there is going to be a at least one
store that advertises that it does tax
returns
on in our case some of them keep the
signs up all year round
and
they are a number of those are CPAs
they made a decision that they wanted to
spend their time as CPAs
taking care of small businesses and
small
on non-profits that did not have enough
money to pay seven thousand dollars a
year for an audit
I talked to one of the CPA Society
people yesterday that said oh well we're
cheaper than all the others we can do it
for 2500.
ah
that's still a lot of money for
for a place like mine which is 22 unit
homeowner units on that has been trying
to keep the costs down for a long time
and is also trying to keep the
maintenance up
and it's a lot more for a library
Society or somebody like that in smaller
towns
so these people I I have known two
others one of whom died on me
on a number of years ago when he was
work when he was doing my taxes as well
so he was capable of doing more but he
never did large audits of the kind that
the people who run the CPI society and
most of the accountants that you will
meet all of the accountants that you
will meet here actually on
on do
is the large audits
this is not what I'm asking for is not
an audit it's kind of a minimal
reassurance and wake-up call to the
membership from the board
on done by an independent and that's
what's in the amendment
if I could pass it out on I've been
trying
um
I haven't gotten an account to actually
approve of this language because they
all say oh but you need to ensure that
there is no fraud
and that requires your seven thousand
dollars
or maybe to some extent you're twenty
five hundred if you can uh there's one
firm that does that apparently and they
sound like a good firm but on doing that
every single year when you don't have
any indication that there is fraud going
on
just it's just too pricey for a lot of
small
places and and also I was thinking that
you would not approve of
uh requiring of a condominium board that
they spend seven thousand dollars I'm
pretty sure we would not approve that is
true and that a lot of them would find
ways to avoid obeying at law and they'd
end up in court anyway
so um this this is
this is just one piece of
of what was done in
in on 239 but it is the part that the
accountants had
had a problem so what you have there is
to pass out is the same thing I have
here
sort of looks like it yeah
yeah it says a just a pure recur and I
mean I guess that's spelled right a
letter for an independent accountant
which compares the bank statements with
the association's annual budget and
records of expenses revenues and changes
in capital Reservoir reserves I put that
on just on on paper because I know you
have to do the amendment if you're going
to we would do the amendment right so
but so actually it's interesting you
said you brought up non-profits yeah do
condo associations have to file a 990 or
a tax return
on condo associations have two methods
that they can use
and homeowner associations right on the
one that we use being small and on not
having a paid management I'm the
management
right and we
um is h11
90 or 1160 I forget which at this point
I haven't had to do those for a while
because the treasurer took them over
but but on the alternative is I believe
the one that you're talking about but
the people behind me can probably tell
you better and if you have ex major
expenses from having a property manager
and uh and a lot of subcontractors of
the property manager it's worth your
while to go
um
and you're actually making a profit on
something uh it's worth your while to go
beyond the
h1160 I think it is which was developed
in the early 1960s and still charges you
30 percent of any profit you make over
the dues and operating on they
on the prophet is can if is beyond the
dues we went
on we did a conservation cut after 70
years of forest growth after a cut
and uh years ago now and
we got back we were not expecting to
make any money off of it but we got back
two thousand dollars and we had to give
10 percent to the town and we had to
give 30 percent to the feds
okay
um so but as far as you know you don't
have to file a 990 or tax return type
thing dude I guess I'll look at the
association does homeowners associations
or condo associations do you have to
file any and what what tax return do
they file
yeah what
yeah
I could tell you later but I don't have
it in my head the reason I say that is I
I'm a trustee of two two non-profits in
my town and I used to do the 990 even
the night when the 990ez was really easy
and then it's not easy anymore so now I
now I have uh other other uh accountants
to do it and you can't you can't hire an
account I mean I got one entity that all
it does is accumulate money I write two
checks a year I mean you know and and uh
they they still charge 600 for that
review of all what I did all the chat
and all the bank statements and
everything and do all that so I mean to
to mandate a condo association to having
to do something like this seems a little
Draconian if the condo association's
really small and and you know paperwork
but I was thinking that the other way
around it is that if they if there is a
tax return filed
than I believe under all tax return laws
that you're required to hand and send a
copy out to all the Association members
I mean I'm required to all the board
members get a copy of the tax return
which would seem to be the same what
you're trying to do with this language
well the 1160
on only asks
how much uh profit did you make over
over the
the dues
and right that's the only problem all it
asks
right that's not really relative to here
because I would say most are not making
money yeah if you're if you're doing one
of the more complicated tax returns you
you really ought to be able to release
that tax return uh I've worked with a
number of condo associations where
um the owners did not see had never seen
it I mean it never occurred to any of
them that they'd see a tax return
on and I've worked with a number of them
where people got away with things like
did I tell you about this one before
a a local Bank in Lincoln
on
on loaned money to a condo board on the
authority of the president
alone
on
for operating expenses and made on and
made itself the manager of all the money
of the condo association and no one else
on the condensation knew it happened
they actually did it twice the first
time there there was a Treasurer the
second time there was no treasurer
okay so this is not an early bill so we
don't have to take action on this right
away
um so if you have you know we could get
some resolution to that
um then the committee can then move
forward well I I think I've gotten about
as far as I can get unless I I could go
to other towns to the main streets and
talk to someone well like I say you're
you're the problem the concept is you
know great but it's to mandate every
condo to have to hand over their
checks and have to to a bookkeeper
um yeah that's gonna you know I was
saying at least a hundred dollars a
month and you just said 200 no no I said
300 once a year
I thought it was 250. 2 500 I thought
you said oh no that was
um a the cheapest of the firms that does
real audits oh I got you okay said that
they told me that they worked hard to
make them affordable and that but to do
something like this is going to take I
mean 2 500 was the least they could do
yeah but to me to do this you're you're
requiring some bookkeeper to every month
and then the question is that you're
only saying only an independent
Association in other words you're
looking for a CPA and I don't know any
CPA he's less than a couple hundred
dollars an hour and what I'm telling you
is that uh there are a bunch of them on
this main streets of our state
but you're looking
Main Street to another to get you
examples from other people okay state
but right fair enough all right so we
will take that up at some other time
because we don't have to take care of
that chairman yes
um representative thank you
um I'm a little confused
um is there going to be an amendment
um changing uh HB 239 from a requirement
for information disclosure to a
requirement to some kind of limited
audit
your microphone's off
on the
uh
I've been struggling to find a way that
on
2B is actually in two parts uh two
stages the the first one the minimalist
approach that would provide some kind of
financial information to the members of
the association which a lot of them do
not get in any form at this point
except a budget that says that this is
how much we're spending this is how much
we're we're
on asking you for for dues we're
requiring dues of you because the law is
actually that
um the the members of an association
have to defeat the budget in order to
change what the dues request is
okay
so I do have an amendment I would I
could certainly pass that out she'll
pass out thank you
okay
uh I think at this point we we we're not
ready to take action yet we can wait to
see how this trickles out
um because this is not this is a late
departure
okay moving on to the next one house
bill 459 relative transaction exempt
from the regulation of business
practices from consumer protection
no I don't have pfas I have 459 first
okay this is one where half the room is
here for
you okay
does anybody who thinks this bill is a
good idea
I don't think it's a good idea but I can
speak to it okay no I just want to give
a person who wants it speak and see for
it okay so
okay uh representative Ammon would like
to speak why he is not for it
I mean this bill to me seems very well
intentioned
every bill has a grain of Truth every
bill has the granted truth
um but we're talking about exemptions
for very highly regulated uh sections of
our economy
and uh I think
giving a private right of action in some
of these instances would have quite a
few unintended consequences and uh
I think you know deferring to the wisdom
that's been built up in statute over
decades maybe longer is the way to uh to
keep the to keep it
okay any other comments from the
committee
yeah Remington feel up
I I guess all path leads are Rome I
think that private right of action in
some of these areas may be wise but
doing the eliminating the exemptions in
the consumer protection act as this bill
seeks to do
is advisable as well that if we seek to
create private rates of action we should
do it in each of the individual areas
organic acts rather than eliminating the
exemption within the consumer protection
act itself
that's an interesting way of doing it I
agree but
okay so uh representative Ammon second
by reference and Fila moves in expedient
to legislate
any discussion on the motion okay the
voting on this is just the eight people
you all know who you are right okay all
those in favor raise your hand one two
three four five
six seven eight
okay motion carries
excuse me Mr chairman
yes just to be sure this list
um looks like it's the older list you
used oh right right that's fine yeah
thank you did you have the older list or
the new list this is like an older one
yeah I know you switched us it didn't
get up there oh it's the wrong one
it's
okay sorry okay all right so yeah so the
correction was that uh representative
Sullivan is now on the
um the the liquor and representative
Gibbs is now on insurance
yeah thank you but you stay right there
look at
the two others
no I want you here yes because in case
there's
partisan type stuff we want to make sure
you're here okay
all right uh
easy enough okay uh House Bill 465
restricting the use of pfas substances
in certain consumer products
uh
let me just trying to figure out what I
want to do on the previous Bill and I'm
not happy okay
all right uh this bill is in early
departure date
uh
uh which one of this bit what did this
bill do
I know
business
this is business this is Banning this is
yeah the carpets right right
um
my problem my number one problem is
enforcement of this
I believe
foreign
um
just does anybody feel really strongly
should we pass this or can we should we
just retain it
I think what's your password I think
it's uh
it's not simple
the um sponsor asked me to to say
something to oh good great go ahead
um wait a second I lost it I lost it
um representative Ebel couldn't be here
today and she wanted to bring to the
committee's attention the fact that
babies and children are playing on these
carpets
um and they can the dust can be inhaled
and adjusted as well as it gets on their
children's hands and toys which I think
is a significant issue that we need to
address she also wanted to make some
clarifying language so I think for for
you know I I think we at minimum should
retain it I'd like to pass it right but
she's saying we need to clarify the
language and
um she wants to clarify the language to
replace the term aftermarket stain and
what water resistant treatment and
um with the term fabric treatment
um
and to make a change to fabric
to meaning a textile made by weaving
knitting or felting natural fibers or
synthetic fibers
but who's going to enforce this statue
who's enforcing it
but is there any evidence that this
stuff these carpets are being still
being sold today
I mean I haven't seen Scotchgard ever
advertised recently but that was called
it's called what
right and so so that people really are
buying this stuff
yeah go ahead remember that section the
the issue is it's in almost every and so
my concern with this bill is not only is
it being sold but it's on
probably this carpet and virtually every
carpet you buy if you go to Home Depot
or your favorite carpet wholesaler
you're going to be buying carpet with
this with pfas on it so there's no
there's no replacement product so you
have a bill from New Hampshire that's
fine and as she said in the testimony
she checked with and there's no
manufacturer of carpets in New Hampshire
that's true there's only two or three in
the United States so you've got a whole
big industry and maybe it's the right
idea
but you're gonna what you're gonna do is
it means nobody in New Hampshire is
going to be able to buy new carpet
if this passes the way it's written and
you'll have big retailers the
enforcement comes Home Depot doesn't
want to be sued so they're just not
going to sell the stuff right
representative Gibbs
I think it's important to note that the
effect
five I would be doubtful about this
sooner because it's pretty clear that
the carpet manufacturers and sellers are
going to need time to gear up to comply
with this uh but an effective date more
than
two years down the road I think will
give them time and if that's not a
sufficient amount of time we should
consider uh an amendment that would move
the effective date farther out but uh
that said
the problem is apparently severe enough
um that I would say provided we give the
manufacturers and sellers time I would
recommend ought to pass
so um this committee over the years has
used the well retain an interim study
methodology before to uh to let to put
um
manufacturer put people on notice
um we I think um again now I'm going to
really uh date myself representative
Crow Dickinson um who is from Conway
area and he kept wanting to uh stop
having Maine come over and and try to
collect taxes from New Hampshire
businesses that were selling appliances
into Maine and evidently Maine would do
that and so he put in a bill and what we
did with the bills we just we always
kept the bill alive right we always
interim study it retained it interim
study we never killed the bill and he
said that that was useful in which uh
and Maine evidently stopped coming into
the state of New Hampshire because we
did that so and I would say in this case
and that that this is a good argument to
retain the bill to let everybody on
those that we're we have a bill and
we're ready to do something if when it
becomes clear that the uh the the
marketplace is not addressing the
problem
I think I think the retaining is a good
idea though I in doing so I I'd actually
would hope that we would work to solve
the problem as right rather than just
saying well it's sort of in this problem
we're not scientists we're not you know
chemical scientists are going to figure
out how to make carpet
that that is stain resistant is that is
that the issue here is that all carbons
I mean I know this carpet you know was
within a year ago we just bought this
new carpet that I saw you know somebody
spilled their coffee on it and it's
still that stain is still there
Washington whenever they whenever they
asked about climate change they all said
we're not scientists so
you know meaning we can't do anything
about it we can't right no well I'd like
to see what we can do okay
right representative Hammond
thank you um I just wanted to
call back to representative Spears
comment a few bills ago about the
marketplace having an incredible power
to change the behavior of Manufacturers
I think this bill is important because
it helps to highlight the idea makes
people aware of it
and uh but it's really up to the
consumer the consumers to put pressure
on manufacturers to change their their
processes I think you can see
a myriad of examples of that working and
being effective
but maybe people wouldn't know about the
problem if this bill was never submitted
so
um
to me the Bill's a mandate and I think
we should tread lightly when it comes to
mandates but consumer education is
important
okay so the Motions retained
and Anybody Everybody okay with that
representative speaker you would like to
comment
and I appreciate you quoting me by the
way
but this is a health issue this isn't
well if you don't have repair this week
all right so someday you will
this is a health issue and we heard
testimony that was devastating as to the
impact of pfas
this bill needs a little more respect I
think than retaining it maybe
something because I have talked to uh
people in my neighborhood some of them
didn't even know what pfas was and
they're drinking it every day and they
don't even know
I looked at the website for
um
uh our water supply
and the groundwater is a mess and they
tell you don't drink the groundwater but
meanwhile the water coming out of uh
pentachuck it's not perfect either it's
not bad yet but it has been going up
they show the graph it's been going up
if we somehow educated people something
because this is getting pretty bad
representative McAleer
um I I agree I think putting an ought to
pass on this gives a little more teeth
than retain I mean everybody's talking
about this problem but nobody's doing
anything about it and I think we have a
chance to at least put one step forward
here by uh ought to pass on this Bill
thank you
are you okay with retaining it no
I'd prefer to ought to pass I think that
puts more teeth into it
I agree
Herbert
I know Herbert's voice a mile away
I agree with the uh the the severity and
emergency
uh people have to know that there is an
emergency going on around them and uh
that's why I would go out to pass put it
into law
and then all of a sudden everybody's got
to talk about it and when that happens
we might get something done but right
now they're just dumping it in the
landfills in in New Hampshire and it's a
and in Merrimack you can't even don't go
fishing and eat the fish that's that's
that's a problem and it's an emergency
in my in my opinion so
I'd run the red red flag up on this
particular piece of legislation how are
you going to enforce it
I don't care whether it's going to be
enforced I want to know that everybody
else knows it needs to be enforced just
like okay this this gentleman talks
about the consumer pushback blowback
because all of a sudden people are just
going
and guess what then you have then you
have something happen Okay
representative post is this more Federal
issue because most of the carpeting
comes from
right and we as We Know
nobody really making carpets in New
Hampshire
well we're theoretically we'll stop New
Hampshire citizens from buying carpet if
from out of state I mean theoretically I
guess we're making Home Depot
responsible
uh in compliance
you would just go across state line to
go buy your carpet right representative
feel it I guess a couple points in terms
of enforcement we've left it to the
department to enforce us
administratively which
we're leave really leaving a lot to
interpretation
um but because of it it's an
administrative interpretation there's
not going to be much teeth to it since
it's administrative rather than a
Judicial inter enforcement so
if we really want to give teeth to it we
aren't giving much teeth since it's
administrative we do risk creating an
island here since we are
only going to be one state out of many
that are doing this and we are very
close to other states and we have cars
so I think we are not really creating uh
much teeth but I do think we also do
need to send a message that we think
this is a important issue so while this
may not have much teeth
we also do need to send that message
um
that I think that the retain at this
point may be the best way to do that and
we try to to work out these issues of
giving a better enforcement mechanism
perhaps than the department of a
Judicial remedy and work out those
issues uh related to uh the the
interstate enforcement of this you know
I think also with the interstate issue
there also is the a potential
constitutional issue that we may be
tripping over so I think retaining it is
going to address these issues that we
may not be seeing at the at the Frisco
fair enough okay representative Jackson
I I want to speak in favor of retaining
this there because there's the other
thing when you look into this there's
the Myriad of unintended consequences
that come along with this bill we've
just explored a few little dips of the
iceberg here in our conversation
you know it's not it's a valid issue
it's affected my own town and my own
well and my and so I'm very familiar
with the problem
but I think that the the proper thing to
do is retain it and come back to it and
then you're going to get testimony on
all of the extraneous issues
representative spear
I I just wanted to comment on uh what
representative post indicated that
people would drive out of state to buy
their carpet and they're certainly
welcome to do that
but with the law in place even if it has
no teeth they know that what they're
doing is I am making a conscious
decision
to go out of state and buy something
that is detrimental to my health
and if you still want to do that knock
yourself out
but at least now they know that it is
detrimental to their health because up
to now so many people have no clue no
they don't
know whatever the reasons the
fundamental problem is there has been no
uh uh study you know peer review study
in showing the direct correlation to
pfas and cancer did you read this study
from that the representative Wendy
Thompson there was the study proven
that they're in
okay
okay I
so I'm assuming that once that occurs
then the FDA will then
ban it so representative Gibbs
relatively to enforcement
um the provision that representative
filio mentioned um that the Department
of Environmental Services uh would be
empowered to adopt rules uh that would
provide
or at least allow for some enforcement
if that enforcement turns out to be
sufficient insufficient after this bill
goes into effect if it's enacted and
after it we've given it a chance to work
if it's insufficient we can come back
and provide it with more teeth
okay
representative Burroughs yeah I'm just I
agree with retaining and I'm thinking
that this may be analogous to cigarettes
smoking where they're required to have a
notice this this may be hazardous to
your health
you know um if I if I particularly if I
have a small child I don't want them
running or my my grandkids I don't want
them running around the carpet with this
stuff in it so that warning I think
could be very powerful I think that's a
good idea
okay so uh the motion is to retain and
so we have this the eight people they
all know who they are all those in favor
retaining raise your hand
uh
yes so this is Ammon Cole Thaxton hunt
McAleer Herbert feel it in spear nope
okay
one two three
four five
not ready to retain
okay
five to one
excuse me no I must be miscounty Who Am
I who did I miss I didn't vote
okay so that's two all right so those
opposed to retaining
those opposed to retaining is one
two
in her thoughts three okay
so it's five to three
okay
all right
uh okay then we have one liquor bill
okay
so the last one uh it's really a liquor
one just in the wrong spot okay so now
we're now we're moved to liquor
subcommittee so liquor everybody know
who's on the liquor something I do okay
Burrows Sullivan and bolia okay is this
right is this the right list okay and I
moved to
OTP
uh no no we have an amendment
did we get my copies of the amendment
yet no
no yeah
I haven't seen an amendment
foreign
you can do
okay so so who has the correct list of
the subcommittees
because I know all right Gibbs yeah
Stuart switched
oh Vincent's on here now okay
okay that's not the right list
okay that includes it includes Osborne
and Vincent
but then there is no okay it's it's
eight yeah it it I'm sorry
okay
uh I have an amendment for this bill
and we're missing a committee assistant
for me to get copies of it
so
um
I think what I'll do is is wait till she
gets back so let's just hold off on that
I can briefly describe it what it what
it says uh basically it says that
um we raised the the penalty to 7 500 we
leave the 10 days in it but it then says
if the employee was not trained
then it's 30 days automatic 30 days
automatic 30 days so this is a carrot
for restaurant owners to get their
employees changed or certainly get the
ones they think might be potential to
over serve their employees to make sure
they get trained because they don't want
to risk being close yes and I have
gotten an okay from the Restaurant
Hospitality
and they and and uh and also I talked to
Maureen Mooney I don't know if she's
here but I talked to Maureen Mooney and
she thought it was
a good idea
okay but I don't have that let me just
uh get that see where we are with that
Amendment and so let's move on to the
next one
all right relative to the closure of
state liquor stores
anybody like this bill no
rgo
okay
all right
representative Julia
yeah
thank you
all right represent polio second by
represent platusic
itl okay everybody the eight know who
they are
uh representative uh bullion
and you second it thank you
okay all those in favor of Ito please
raise your hand
one two three four five
six
seven
who's my eight
yeah I got him who's uh
so I get Vincent Sparrow Julio and
Stewart
right
through Sullivan
Sullivan okay it's eight eight nothing
right
okay
146.
okay okay
167. all right next one
yeah
167 relative to Nano uh Brewing license
okay
um so my understanding is that the
commission uh is is going ahead to
approve that particular location because
he did have a proper
um to but bringing up the bigger
question of
um why are we picking on Nanos when it
comes to uh location and that
unfortunately was just a history of the
Nano legislation which was that um no
one ever visualized a beverage
manufacturer of doing their doing having
manufacturing bottling canning whatever
inside their home or their Barn it was
only that issue only came up when it
came up to Nanos
and Nanos the whole idea was that you
would start out at as a home business
and then you would expand and that's the
reason why it was written in there but
for all sense of purposes you can't
manufacture any alcohol uh in your home
so I I recommend that we just retain
this bill so that uh a we can see what's
coming over from the Senate and B is
that we then kind of clarify that that
this is not something we're picking on
Nanos but rather than this is true for
anybody who's manufacturing
representative Sullivan yeah so I mean
this is more procedural I don't really
know how the process works but yep
um
we can retain it but I I guess my gut is
we should probably pass it or I would I
think we should ought to pass it because
there is something coming out of the
Senate which supposedly will maybe take
care of this but there's a lot of other
things in that bill which might make it
not pass to me it seems like a very
sensible build we're literally taking
out what like four words or something
and so I I would motion to pass whatever
the right way to do it is and then I
don't know what the process is you would
know better than I uh if the Senate bill
passes and we like it and it's going to
pass here then does it just supersede
this or does that create some sort of
problem down the line
um
and again I I listened in on the Senate
hearing on their bill but I had did not
have it I didn't pull it up
uh if they're if they're crossing over
the same RSA
um but the uh
then there is it can be a potential
conflict so in that case the the Senate
would probably just kill our bill so I
mean you know so so it would not take it
but my my only concern with saying that
is is I don't want if us if we were to
repeal that
section it would theoretically say okay
we've solved this problem for him so he
can get his Nano license well there are
other people too like I I researched
this and there's been multiple other
ones he's not the only example of
mistake there's at least four or five I
was able to come up with to have better
have the exact same problem that they
were forced to take a full beverage
license rather than a nano license yeah
so this is not unique to him he's just
the one who brought it okay so I guess I
you know the that
um we need again we need let's see what
there's I mean just it seemed logical to
take this out I what they're saying is
it's still law it's federal law
no I understand so I was taking out our
law the one thing that scares me about
taking out of our law
is that someone says oh I can do it
because the state state doesn't escape
repealed it so therefore I can do it but
the federal law is still in effect so
like with this example he had to work
with the federal regulators and he did
and they approved that exactly so I mean
there's some level of enforcement going
on at the federal level which presumably
would still have to occur
and that's what I would want to I would
rather see that in the our statute but
not just for Nano
for everybody in other words to say is
oh you're okay because you you can go
get your beverage license
no
so you're saying there's four other
people doing it I'd love to know who
those four are yeah because I I like to
hear their story and see what happened
here how did the feds have a problem
with their location or what they were
doing so then I'm somehow I feel like
we're not getting the full story
you follow me because it's against
federal law
it's against federal law in your
dwelling but in this case that we know
with the man the gentleman who testified
the federal the federal Regulators were
totally okay with it it was the state
that caused the problem correct and so
and you're saying there's four other
people that are just like this
from my understanding yes I have I would
have I can send you I can send you to
the list when uh yeah okay that what is
this bill number
167 167.
uh okay this is a late delivery
this is a late delivery I don't know
Aiden do you want to talk about this at
all
or is Chief oh she's here okay there's
the G I didn't see you I'm hiding back
there
okay
so Chief are you aware that there are
four other locations that have you have
to speak to the microphone
there are four other locations that have
the same problem
good morning Mr chairman
and committee members uh yes we we've
identified probably
I'm going to say approximately six that
we are reaching out to to do the same
assessment that we did with the
gentleman that we spoke of that
testified last week
um to we we don't know if they fall into
this same scenario but we're willing to
go to come to the table and see if they
do or not under the standard that we're
holding everybody to our interpretation
of it okay so we don't have to take
action on this bill yet because this is
a late delivery so we will have another
subcommittee and we hope you can tell us
how you resolve all for real five people
or whatever six say people make sure
it's all taken care of absolutely okay
great
no we're not going to do anything with
this bill right now because it could be
passed
because the amendment I would drive past
is you know if it gets Federal approval
then it should be fine
regardless of what type of manufacturer
you are
um
thank you
okay
so Jason or could you could you just pop
in and see if if Carrie showed up
she was there is she there now
okay that's the next one
5 31. all right
anybody want to speak for this bill
okay who would like to make your motion
and expedient
all right representative
and second event Representative Vincent
okay
all right all right uh representative
below second by Representative Vincent
moves in expedient to legislate any
discussion on the motion scene none all
those and the eight members of the
subcommittee please raise your hands
two
this is the liquor
live
who else has got Solomon is out of the
room okay
and who else is on this who am I missing
um
no he's back
just so you know you're not supposed to
walk out of the room we're about to go
into voting mode
apologies so you might learn that some
days that you want to walk and that can
be intentional but I wasn't sure that
you were intentionally walking out on
this one okay so what's the committee
who's the list you get the list again
okay
so this is Aunt uh this is petusic Walsh
hunt Sullivan Vincent
Below in Osborne okay I'll raise your
hands if you're for itl
okay one
two three
four
five six who am I missing
uh Jackson no I'm looking in the wrong
list I'm looking the wrong list
right
so
okay
good
what's that
okay all those who are voting for itl
okay
Burrows right your vote excuse me you're
voting against itl say why sure
um I know that and I thought my I
thought my team was Voting um was not
voting itl I guess I was wrong
um I know that the concern is that we're
going to be putting out uh maybe uh
hurting some businesses but and um my
feeling is we're also going to be really
damaging human beings lives
um and um
that's why I can't vote vote for Ito
okay
all right
okay so one anyway
how do I just listen
I know it's supposed to be eight but I
see I see Sullivan written twice
[Music]
if I can comment okay sure go ahead
representative so I
I it was stated a couple of different
times that it takes the control away
from Concord
really you know it takes the control
away from us uh to set the tax and uh
and it was going to put it in the uh the
department of revenues administration's
hands and I didn't think that was right
so that's why I am going for Ito
okay
so the vote I have is because we're
missing walls so I have the vote is six
to one
okay
all right
okay uh
okay next up is 612 relative to the fees
for New Hampshire and wine manufacturers
okay
so Aiden you're the one that's handling
this one
the chief you
actually I'd like to see the chief I
think that you know I want to see the
chief
all right so I I did a little homework
and uh well Aiden did a little homework
for me
and we find out that when it comes to
wine we do have a de minimis license
already for wine
and uh so how many were they how many uh
there was
I can pull it up
um
getting that information for you now sir
so de minimis license this was the issue
is if you're just a Farm Stand a farm
and you want to make wine
so you can get a
license to make wine
and sell it there on your farm and the
license is a hundred dollars
and there are
36 out of 50 that are under 30 36 36 out
of 50. out of 50. so that means there
are more of these people than
than who really are making uh more wine
or over a thousand thousand was it more
than a thousand cases chairman thousand
cases which just seems like a lot of
wine so then the next question I said is
so of those 36 who are at this five
percent they're paying the five percent
how much are they contributing to the
tax revenue
which is think about it now they're the
majority there's 36 of them more so that
leaves 14 of the other ones
that is approximately 108 000 which
represents about a third of the total
revenue okay so there are a third of the
revenue but they're and they're
generating a hundred and eight
so the question is in this the way the
bill was presented it had two parts to
it had one was uh I don't know release
of all the fees or something in other
words to get rid of the tax is that am I
correcting with the what was in the bill
someone have a copy of the bill
there were several aspects to this bill
the first was changing the sample sizes
we're not going to change sample sizes
uh the second was changing the uh tax
um code the fee codes so it was 50 cents
a gallon changing it to 50 cents a
gallon right okay correct
as opposed to five percent of uh the
sales
and then the last section uh was an
added paragraph
um regarding the exemption of 100
gallons per year for a household with
more than with one person and up to 200
gallons of wine per year for a household
with two or more people uh from the tax
in paragraph four
oh that was an actual
they didn't have to pay any tax right
correct right so I guess that's where I
was focused in on 50 cents a gallon that
seems really awkward to because you
don't we don't really have that in our
system to be able to apply that tax
right that's correct chairman
yes it's beer but beer the tax uh
reporting is done by the beer
manufacturers
the commission doesn't come in and when
they do audit it but they they don't
and and you know obviously
the reason why we had set the five
percent was that they
um in lieu of a fact that that we're not
selling them through the commission
which was really the bottom line for us
is the state of New Hampshire is that
um when when the prohibition ended we
gave beer we let beer go through
Distributors and wine and distilled was
going to go through the commission
commission was making all that margin uh
before my time
so don't blame me before my time the uh
the legislature and his wisdom did
decide to allow wine to be sold through
the same channel as the beer
distributors I.E convenience stores and
grocery stores and at that time
um the the uh margin it was then is that
they're they're buying it from the
commission and there's a discount uh
it's the only discount I know in the
world in which the more you buy the
lower your discount is but if we got
away with that for somehow
um but but notwithstanding that if you
are uh self-distributing that wine so
you're not going through the commission
and you're bringing that wine into the
retail outlets
um that and or you're selling it
yourself that's where the five percent
kicks in that's where the five percent
tax kicked in
so
um
at this point
um and this bill
uh
this is an early departure so we have to
make a decision on what to do with this
bill
um we don't have to do it today we can
wait a week we can think about this but
the question I you know was is it uh is
it worth it to reduce the tax I mean
we're already making the fee pretty de
minimis I mean it's 100 fun you know
feed seems pretty pre-de minimis uh to
whether we really want to mess around
with the tax
or not
so I guess I'm leaving it up into what
the committee committee feels about this
bill
representative
um thank you what would be the
difference in Revenue if we went to 50
cents a gallon versus five percent
thank you representative I do have those
that would be in the fiscal note right
uh it is but very quickly so you don't
have to go through that on on your own
the total revenue that was brought in uh
based on the five percent in 2021 was 30
367 thousand dollars approximately
um that's based on the five percent of
sales if those same Figures were
calculated at the 50 cents a gallon uh
it would be approximately an 87 percent
loss in revenue and equate to forty
seven thousand dollars approximately
and and we do have a a constitutional
requirement that our taxes is equal and
proportionate
so to reduce the tax to one group of
people is technically unconstitutional
in New Hampshire
so
what do you mean it would reduce it then
I would say the beer well in other words
no no that that's that would be apples
and oranges so that if let's say we said
okay for those people who are the small
manufacturers you know these these under
a thousand who are only paying a hundred
dollar fee if we were to reduce their
tax rate and not reduce the total tax
rate and remove reduce the five percent
because let's face it that five percent
is probably you know the majority of
that is probably paced by
um the Mead guy uh midnight meenery and
and uh and LaBelle
I mean probably there's a hand I don't
know there's a couple of them could firm
there's a couple of guys that make a lot
you know who make play the fight Lion
Share of that so that would be dis
that's that because of the same category
they're both wine they're doing you
can't have different tax rates in other
words no there's no uh
so yeah representative Vinson
thank you Mr chairman so I just want to
give you my spin on this
um we heard a testimony uh from one of
the manufacturers of a wine a winery uh
which is very few wineries
what I took from her and her testimony
very few wineries so when I look at this
as his three pots to this bill uh so we
start with number one allowing wine
manufacturers to give a bottle example
you know I don't think that's a big deal
I really don't uh however I think the
other two do affect taxes and whatever
it may be for the state but um so I'm
not sure I mean I don't like all of this
bill but I would be certainly for a wine
producer which is so many so few of in
the state to give a bottle of wine into
sample wine uh I don't have a problem
with that
the other two about changing taxes I
don't know if I'm for that but I just
wanted to bring that to the committee uh
I hope I'm hope I'm staying this
correctly I mean this is what I'm seeing
here from my recollection and notes
yes where where is that giving the
bottle of wine uh
for a first part of the bill allowing uh
we are on 612 right yeah okay sometimes
that's happened too sorry but allowing
wine manufacturers to give a bottle uh
as a sample under certain conditions
and her testimony was that there's only
I believe two or three wine
manufacturers
in a state that actually grow the grapes
and do the wine or one maybe it was
and they wanted to kind of give the wine
away because they didn't actually meet
the food requirements if I'm correct so
do they really want to give the bottle
away or do they want it in charge rooms
and meals taxes
oh it states here to give a bottle of
the sample under this what line are you
looking at uh uh right under the bill
right first one allowing wine
manufacturers to give a bottle
as a sample under certain conditions
I think it's a line 11. yeah I see that
I'm sorry I'm on the front of the bill
right so they're going from you're going
from the two ounce glass per person and
then a full
open bottle of wine to groups of two or
more
we got two or more right so there's more
than one part to this I see it's more
than just a tax it's
well
there's a lot of stuff going on yeah
yeah I get you I just want to bring it
right so I guess the discussion is
someone's coming in and taking a sample
of the wine
and they can and under our law they can
either uh charge for that sample or or
if they want to they they wouldn't have
they collect the rooms and meals tags
you know meals tax or they can just give
that sample for free
and so then now you've cracked the book
The Bottle open and that's the only
person that day is going to come in
because this is a little standoff in the
country but I also think that it has
something to do if the committee
remembers correctly about them having
the license to to give or sell the
bottle because of non not being able to
meet the food requirement
I mean am I the only one who
scooters
food requirements when is the food
requirement I don't know the food we
ever had the food we're worried about
the food requirement because we did that
for the Nanos okay so the Nanos we did
we had we had a nano Plus
and a nano plus was if you had a food
truck
okay but at the end of the day the the
the
um the Nano only can give away only he
can give a he can a sample is a glass a
pint he can give a pint
rather than just one because we were
thinking the Nano guy won't have a lot
you know so but those Nano guys are not
giving that Pine away
they're they're charging for it right
and uh so
you know I I hate to kill the bill
because I don't know I guess I don't
know all the nuances in there I I would
say is I have a problem with the 50 Cent
a gallon tax because of you know the
five percent it's got to be across the
board
um and
um we already have the hundred dollar
fee so I really don't see and we don't
have
the ban on it for growing it in your
making the wine inside your house right
that's not in this statute
um
Mr chairman I I mean I all my notes
basically I think it was a logical thing
but this is the first I've heard about
it potentially being unconstitutional so
I think that's something we should
explore well that's unconstitutional if
we were to decide not to we would apply
that 50 Cents Only to the small guy
right right okay but to go 50 cents a
gallon across the board we're going to
lose 800 800 000 dollars
right right
but
actually correct me if I'm wrong it
would be considerably more because if we
were to do it across the board we're
talking about every bottle of wine
that's sold no this is only yeah well
it's only yeah no he's he's done that
all the way across the board so I don't
know no he he's doing it only for these
this group of of small wine producers
across the board for all wines no for
all wines no that would be no we don't
charge five percent tax on that
because we're only charging a five
percent tax no as a matter of fact we
don't have a five percent tax we have a
25 to 30 percent margin
when we sell those wines
okay there's no tax involved the five
percent tax is only if you're bypassing
the commission
you just as soon kill it
isn't this petusic's bill
[Laughter]
you want to separate it I I would just
assume retaining because I would like to
I would like to
I would like to think about how they're
selling in other words the terms of as
comparing it to the Nano guys again
um
I mean they can they're certainly
selling a bottle of wine if it's corked
and then and it's funny they're going on
in the old corking law
The Unfinished wine
how they how they they brought that
Statute in
which is
um
I mean theoretically they could sell
that whole bottle right even though it's
been cracked open and a sample was given
they could that's correct they could
still sell that bottle yeah
what does this language do what does
this language do what different what is
this doing different than its current
law so the only thing that I can surmise
out of this and thank you chairman is
increasing the
uh sample sizes from six ounces from
five ounces to six ounces right for two
samples that's 12 ounces per person
and 24 ounces per two people
a standard 750 milliliter bottle is 25
ounces so they're saying I believe what
the intent here is if you serve four
glasses or wine two for per person at
six ounces that's an entire bottle
that's crazy but we don't really care
that it's a bottle that's that's just a
it's a meaningless that's correct it's a
red herring if you ask me because we we
would say you can you can easily sell
that bottle cork it and take it away
because the restaurant license has and
the way this language reads I I would
like to bring up that again this is
essentially making a wine bar out of a
wine manufacturing license
so this it's not only a bottle it's
bottles for two or more people there's
no limit right right and that that you
know we were we've kind of held the line
on that with Nanos
so
okay
um I guess we could kill it sorry John
you can vote now
right does anybody anybody think
otherwise anybody anybody feel sorry for
drawing
okay
no we can't
yeah
we gotta kill it
okay
no no no no okay
uh
all right representative below
and
who would like to second the motion
do people rather retain it with rather
retain it or
know if you put so I'm not gonna put my
name on it bro yes
okay representative Sullivan
thank you okay
uh all right so the motion is in
experience to legislate
and we have seven people here all those
in favor of the motion raise your hand
one
is it yeah
three four
it's seven okay great and Mr chairman if
I could just uh say that maybe it being
Rewritten and coming back again would be
a better thing because it was a little
out of character so to speak it was just
it was a laundry room it was I mean I
think they had a good point but I just
think it was Rewritten right but and I
guess I my problem mistake was I forgot
that we had already
created the 100 license right so that's
where I thought it had legs is to make
sure we had the de minimis license okay
okay next
legalization and regulation okay so um I
have sent out everyone a uh a new new
version right
um I'm sure none of you have had a
chance to read through it but or see the
analysis
um I guess what I will definitely be
scheduling this again next week uh and
uh for anybody in the audience who's
interested in this bill
um uh you can ask Carrie which sometimes
she's at her desk to have her email it
to you or you can ask any member of the
committee to email it to you
um and so that you can see where where
we're at with an amendment
um I I
I think this amendment uh will hopefully
uh uh survive the test of time when it
goes over to the other body and to the
governor's office
um because it it is definitely a hybrid
but it uses I I I would like to say is
if I were there in the room back in 1933
or 34 after the repeal the prohibition
yeah
my hair was truly platinum blonde no
um that um I'm sure when they made that
decision to go through to create the
Liquor Commission and to say this is
something that clearly a lot of people
is very concerned about how it's being
made available to the public
um they they
resigned they went to this commission
idea uh knowing that that theoretically
we the state can control a what's in
there knowing more what's what's knowing
it's safe and no it's not you know what
the safety of the product knowing where
it came from and B is that it it was
certainly uh would reduce the risk of
selling it to underage people uh and uh
so I thinking that that maybe is
probably the right way to go
and anyway I'm hoping yes representative
Osborne I think just to clarify when you
said you're scheduling this again for
next week will that be a public hearing
or another work session um I am not
treating this as a non-germaine
Amendment I'm treating this as a very as
a germane Amendment so that will be the
time in which the subcommittee would
vote on it but I I didn't think
everybody had a chance to read it and so
that's the reason why I'm scheduling
another subcommittee next week and but
then we would vote on it so uh in terms
of next week we would do
um I'm looking at Thursday morning
Thursday morning subcommittees and then
Thursday afternoon we'll exec
bringing the amendment forward
so
um
I I hope this is a Commerce Amendment
rather than take total ownership for it
for myself
but I would hope that that everybody in
the committee can feel that you're
comfortable with this
um but in terms of who I work with
um is I I my focus was making sure that
it was enforceable and structurally can
can work within the system that we have
now
and the amendment does that does that
and I sent it out yeah I sent it out
this morning oh this morning
we
should yes you'll have it in your having
your email did I send it out last night
oh I said it out last night I'm sorry I
did send it out last night
yes representative Gibbs uh thanks um
just a question
um
why is this bill being considered
separately from house bill 544. so 544
is not an early bill
this one is early
so
um that's why I chose to do it this way
and get get the ball rolling
but I would say that the other one the
544 was heavily used in the structure of
this one
so that's why I would call it a hybrid
of the two
and that was last year's bill that did
pass the house over Wembley last year I
mean it just does it make more sense
um usually when we have two bills like
that we we would hold on to the second
one as a retain so that we have a
vehicle to work on something if if the
other one didn't have the outcome that
we were hoping for
don't representative
terms of the sponsors
[Laughter]
right foreign
absolutely and and and I would say that
that I was keenly aware that I I didn't
think it was a good idea to have state
employees selling a state unionized
employees selling marijuana in bongs
and then we would have the other one in
case
okay
so
stay tuned to next week on that one
all right and last but not least
repealing the drug affordability bill
okay
I've been to one
um
Mr chairman yes
um why is repealing the drug
affordability board on the liquor
subcommittee
uh that really uh why did I
uh
I guess I was thinking that we needed to
move on this one that this had an early
departure date I think is
but it doesn't so never mind we don't
need to discuss it at all
we don't need to discuss it
we'll do that some other time
and it's not an early bill right
okay
with that we're all done
oh wait a minute now I do have one more
um
yeah where's my did she ever show up
[Music]
and
it's awesome right okay so unfortunately
she's still not here
um so what it will do is I will I will
email that out to everyone
um but it what I'll do is uh given that
we've talked about it a little bit and
everybody feels somewhat comfortable
with it I will go ahead and have the
amendment drawn up so that we'll be
ready for the next for next week to to
accept it
279.
okay
so if anybody has a problem with it with
this by turning this into a carrot
please let me know what you think but it
seemed like we're all
yeah but
this is purposes we're making an
mandatory protection because that means
if you have one employee who's over
served somebody you're shut down for 30
days and what I've heard is if you're
shut down for 30 days you're you're done
yeah
I guess we'll have to talk to the mic
because theoretically this is public
we'll just I remember uh the objections
that representative Sullivan had that
there were only like three cases that uh
The Liquor Commission had to look into I
mean yeah I guess I can speak
to minimize it was to Minimus let me let
me say my point
um I think there's a hundred cases where
people walked out of the bar totally
zongo and didn't get in an accident and
and those are the ones that we want to
prevent so it's not a case of the ones
that got caught it's a case of the
potential one so I I just don't think
that was a good argument that's all
thank you
ouch oh well
my my argument
are we talking about now I mean I can we
theoretically I did say where this this
was unfinished off in this argument
until we see the thing where we can go
at it now
but at the end of the day you're okay
with our
um
with the amendment the amendment saying
that that if the employee was untracked
I was the one who was on our caucus was
the most opposed to this bill which is
why he's referencing ah gotcha that's
where this is coming from right so how
do you feel about this this compromise
I don't really like the bill in general
I think uh this is my personal view
there's a very sad story yeah and it
moved all of us who heard it but I don't
think that this would have saved her
life and I don't think that this would
will prevent things like that in the
future and I think it's a solution in
search of a problem and it looks like
it's something we're gonna do that may
have unintended consequences which for
me are concerning
um I think that
the bar community and bar culture
everybody thinks the negative it they
think of people going there and getting
wasted and driving home and
irresponsible things which do happen I
don't dispute that I think as long as we
have legalized alcohol that we're going
to have those issues but my bigger
concern is the potential unattended
consequences of chilling the bar culture
and
some people might be okay with that you
might be okay with that though if you're
somebody who doesn't frequent bars or
doesn't understand some of those bars
but when you do go to a really busy bar
it's a lot to ask for a bartender to be
able to identify somebody who maybe has
had too much to drink and there if
there's three or four hundred people in
there and you're like serving them
within 30 seconds like it's hard to
evaluate that they might go to other
bars or other bartenders so nobody has a
real accurate account on that and I
think when people are talking about bars
I think a lot of people in this room
probably are going to places where it's
a sit-down bar not the stand-up Club
type bar that people in their 20s are
going to and and those those
establishments for all the negative that
they get on the news or also bring a lot
of positive to our society in terms of
people meeting their spouses there
people socializing they move to a
community that's where they start to
make friends like putting a chill in
unintended chilling consequence on that
industry I think is something we need to
think about and and I think
this is a very tragic story I don't know
that this law the way it's mended or the
law that's on the books now is going to
prevent
anything I really don't think it will so
that's my view and I think we need to
really be cognizant of my chill being
industry well let's go back to his
original statement which is I think we
should just mandate
that everybody gets the training
well we know that doesn't work because
the employee could only be there for a
week and then you decided they're not
going to work out so mandating that is
not a good idea but if we could
incentivize
the owners of the of the bars and
restaurants incentivize them to get that
training
but again I mean what's the difference
because that that if your argument is
that you can't mandate it because they
might only be there for a week they
might only be there for weekly
incentivize or you mandate it right it's
like see to me it seems like the exact
same thing you can incentivize all you
want if that if that bartender is there
for three weeks and they leave just like
if it's mandated it's the same problem
we haven't solved a problem well but it
goes back to the decision by the
commission
was that
where they found fault to the owner to
the restaurant owner was that no
employee had training at all
[Music]
and so we're saying is how do we how do
we get over that hump because we didn't
mandate it
that we want we want them to to get that
training because hopefully then that way
the the commission would not have to use
that as a reason for why that over
serving so occurred I mean if if the
owners are training their staff right
like I guess it's through the liquor
commission's website or whatever they
have some sort of yeah yes how effective
that is I think we should discuss too I
don't I haven't seen it but I would be
very curious I mean I think honestly if
we're gonna just get it out in the open
is it going to be any different than
when I sat in my all my corporate jobs
and I had to do sexual harassment
training like does it actually teach you
like we had here
a state house you did go to it right I
didn't go to that no I got good at it
after the last 15 years of uh sitting
but no my point is how effective are
these training maybe they're good maybe
they're not or is that just like a way
to to hide it but
um I think that would be an interesting
thing to understand if we think we're
just
do we think it's going to be effective
are we passing a law that can have
unintended consequences and it's really
going to accomplish nothing and I think
if we're doing it simply because it's a
really sad story and we feel like we
need to react because of a sad story
because that's not a good reason but if
we're doing it because we truly believe
it's going to lead to a safer better
society and it's worth the unintended
consequences then fine but I think we
need to think about it in that light and
not just simply knee-jerk reaction sad
story better do something okay
representative thackson
so
here's you know I didn't I thought
here's the here's the thing
and I'm going to tell you that I'm
probably the only person in this room I
hope I'm the only person in this room
that can say this but I had a daughter
who was killed under similar
circumstances Jesus so
I understand the pain
this bill doesn't fix the problem
if we want to talk about training
bartenders or bar managers
I think that may be a really good
conversation but that's not what this
bill does
I think that
and you know you could have bartenders
bar managers who get licenses like they
do in other states issued by the Liquor
Commission however that and again this
is and that license travels with that
individual
rather than that solves the problem of
every time I hire a bartender I have to
train them you hire a trained person and
then it's more on them
so the point is
I think this bill is defective because
it is a bill where it wants to address a
person's personal pain
it doesn't really fix the problem is
there really a difference if I'm running
a bar in Keene and I'm doing twenty
thousand dollars a night is there really
a difference between twenty five hundred
dollars and seventy five hundred dollars
I don't think so
so the only real achievement of this
bill is I now have to paint a Scarlet
Letter on my door that says when I'm
closed for no we I took that one that's
out so I think I think there's an issue
but I don't think this bill
achieves that right but but it was the
training piece the training if you have
that right I'm saying that's where we
turn this bill into is an is a carrot to
get training
okay that's
it's I still don't think it fixes up I
think there's a better way to do the
training and then you get in the whole
go down the get out in the Weeds on how
you can do the training representative
spear I'm going around so you guys you
know I know you all want to speak
I think that I think it's
thank you I I think that the bill is
lacking I went and looked at what they
do in other states and other states
include jail sentences shutting down all
kinds of stuff that we're not even
looking at
but I do believe that the bar that is
busy enough that it's making all this
kind of money
needs to do something need and and
you're right I don't know the solution
and hearing these these other things
just because a bar is busy that doesn't
mean that we let them off the hook this
bill is not maybe not thorough enough
because I think if we look at some other
states we'll find some really thorough
stuff that's happening
I don't know what I'm saying okay
letting everybody off the hook
representative Gibbs uh thank you uh
regarding the effectiveness of training
um there was just a comparison made
between the effectiveness of this kind
of training for bartenders and uh sexual
harassment training and as someone who
has actually done a lot of sexual
harassment training over many years uh
and who also attended the recent
legislative sexual harassment training
uh I can say that one of the uh
important ways in which it is effective
and I think also the training discussed
here can also be effective is it wakes
people up to the problem and that's a
very important element there you go and
representative McVay you have the last
word
um I talked to my friend the bartender
or the owner of Wildcat Tavern yeah and
he's telling me that the training is
quite frankly not effective it's it
that's where it really I realize this is
an incentive to to train but I think the
Liquor Commission should come out with a
very stringent training program and and
take it out and make people do it I
think that's the real yeah but don't you
think the reason he said that to you is
to to explain to you why he never
enforced his police to do it no he he
said I'm willing to pay a hundred
dollars per employee to have them
trained properly but he doesn't you can
do he could do it outside he could go
out and get another training course he
doesn't have to use the state course I
think he's recognizing that and quite
frankly might do that okay good so that
would be a good thing
all right with that we will close our
subcommittee
I I think the other thing I don't like
about this bill in general but you're
saying that just because that bar is
busy they shouldn't have no idea
Eric I don't think that's what he was
saying
yeah
all right we'll open up the public
hearing
on
House Bill 86 relative to probing the
state from Contracting the Chinese
government-owned Affiliated technology
manufacturers
did I just see
representative Roy down in he was just
settling in for lunch downstairs wasn't
he
um
how could he even miss this
America
you know you don't think you should you
know you get it 24 hours of life before
we kill it
I could have sworn I just saw him
downstairs
you can go ahead and tell us why you're
opposed to it all right thank you
um all right good afternoon Mr chair
members of the committee my name is
Dennis Goulet I'm the commissioner for
the Department of Information Technology
uh I'm here it's it's odd to be
testifying in opposition to this uh but
I think you'll understand once I lay the
details down for you um I I really do
applaud the sponsor for for um you know
paying attention to our you know what's
going on in the world with respect to
our you know
some of our friends and and some not
friends who are who are using technology
um in in ways that aren't in our best
interest as a country but um but there's
I I think there may be another approach
that we can use that that might be more
effective and and wouldn't require
legislation at this time
um so one of the things about this if
you read the language it's very focused
on China we have other countries who are
who are using technology in ways that
aren't in our uh in our best interests
either so um you know we look we would
look to
um anything that we wanted to put in
place we would want to be able to Target
um
any other entity who is using technology
in a way that that we felt was not in
the interest of our state or our
citizens
um you know for example uh already in
statute there's a Kaspersky software
which is a lot we believe is somewhat
aligned with the Russian government is
is not allowed in state government for
example today it's a very specific
legislation on that
um we also believe that the
um that there's an approach that we've
done some research on what's going on
with in the federal government and other
states and the approach rather than kind
of saying this type of company we will
not allow to contract with or do
business with we'd like to maintain a
specific list
and I'll get into that more in a minute
um and and have that list be dynamic
so that for example um you know if you
if you've um ever bought something on
Amazon you you may notice that you buy
some thing maybe it's a small electronic
device or whatever and you know eight
months later if you want another one
that company doesn't seem to exist
anymore well that's a fairly common
thing that the Chinese government's
doing so having a dynamic list of who
whose which companies are prescribed
we're seeing as trending toward a best
practice in cyber security
um so um and then finally right now we
don't need this because the the
governor's executive order
um
202209 really does cover this presently
and what we talked to the governor's
office about when we were working
together with them on that executive
order was that we put the order out and
then we look for unintended consequences
things we learn from it
um
things that we might want to add or
remove change and then seek legislation
or get it in Statute in a future time
like perhaps next session or whatever so
and then we would offer ourselves
um to help write said legislation so
that it so that it follows what we're
seeing as best practice in the nation
um
and in executive order right now we do
have that Dynamic list of companies so
there is a list there now
but if we needed to change that list
because you know the Chinese government
had pivoted or the Soviets were the
Russians were doing something different
we could actually pivot that list very
quickly with the governor's approval in
legislation we could do that too we'd
have we need a different mechanism but
but I think that's really so I'm in
favor of this concept 100 the approach I
think we we may want to do a different
approach
um that's it for my testimony
any questions from the Committee Member
representative spear
thank you I looked at the list of
components and companies and all kinds
of things that the federal government
and the FCC have already put on their
list of do not touch
uh and are you saying that that list
isn't comprehensive enough
uh well that that is the that's uh
that's a subset of the list that we put
in the governor's executive order so
that's I think we added a couple other
things in there as well and it depends
on you know the federal government
actually has multiple lists
too so this is I'd call what what we had
in the executive order a superset of
what we were aware of at that moment and
if we become aware of other things other
uh technologies that we feel the state
shouldn't be using we would uh amend the
list
uh representative Ammon
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony
um I'm just looking at the executive
order that you referenced
uh you're you're directed to remove
software and Hardware
uh from the state's Networks
um could you just give us maybe an
update on what you found in your Audits
and what you've had to do to transition
away from
away from uh technology that might give
the Communist Party of China information
about the state of New Hampshire right
well the good news is we've been pretty
Vigilant even without executive order or
legislation we've been Vigilant and
trying not to use this technology so it
really didn't the executive order didn't
cause us much trouble where we where we
had a bit of a challenge is how do we
assure that we're not loading tick tock
tick tock I almost said Tic Tac onto uh
onto State devices like we we know that
for example on the our computers we
control them very closely but the mobile
devices we didn't have as close a
control on so we actually acquired some
technology from a company we were
already doing business with who's not
Chinese and um and we're now managing
the or we're in the process of
implementing that and we'll be managing
the state mobile devices as well so that
we're not seeing tick tock on those
devices the other challenge is there's
some legitimate State business that
occurs on Tic Tac might Tick Tock it
might be investigations or whatever so
we had to figure out a way to do that
and still in compliance with the
executive order so um you know basically
not connecting those devices to the
state Network
representative Terry thank you
so do I understand that you um have uh a
screening process uh with a set of
parameters or or criteria in place to be
able to vet any
um existing and potential uh uh new
purchases of software Hardware so that
it doesn't become a discovery later on
because there wasn't a process in place
to to preempt this sort of thing from
happening correct
um one of the one of the steps the
executive branch
I.T has pretty broad Authority on
contracts and all of the contracts come
before me
um before they move forward to go to a
governor and Council and the other
entities that would review them inside
of my process our chief information
security officer and other technology
directors review each contract and we
would go back to the agency and say you
know if we found an issue with whether
whether it was the company or the um or
the um the terms of the contract they
felt might not be safe from a security
or privacy perspective so we have we
have eyes on it and typically what we
advise in and we try to do this with the
agencies because we do have I.T presence
in almost all the agencies
we try to do that process in stream
versus it coming to me at the end and
then we have a problem with it rather we
would try to find oh you know we
shouldn't be for example some of the
companies on this list on the executive
order always come in as low bidders
always not an accident and so
um and so States actually have some of
this technology in place and now they're
like holy smokes I have to replace all
this really expensive stuff we we don't
just you know for technology purchases
we don't just go with low bidder we go
with what makes sense so we wouldn't put
a a Huawei solution in or a solution
that contained knowingly contained the
Huawei technology for example
any other questions representative
thank you I just have another question
um I don't I'm not uh I'm not an expert
in this by any means so I'm just asking
based on news reports that I've heard
um the 5G technology that's been rolled
out uh some of that is or can be based
on
Chinese Hardware manufacturers Just in
our uh the the cellular networks that we
all use is that a fair statement yes and
so yeah so that the um and you're
bringing up a pretty large issue that
we're starting to see more and more in
society is what we call a supply chain
issue right you're paying attention not
just to where the end product is
purchased from but where the components
come from and whether there's stuff
embedded in that and it's I wouldn't say
that it's it's limited to 5G technology
either I would say the 4G LTE and other
Technologies potentially in the
commercial sector could potentially have
that issue as well and and that's one of
the reasons why the Department of
Defense really got strict on their um
you know their procurements and and
where we got a lot of this list from was
DOD they did they actually had the
resources to do the research which we
didn't follow further question and so
the cellular networks that we all use as
we travel around the state
um
I don't know the answer to this question
have you looked into seeing
uh if any of that Hardware is it would
violate this list because I think the
devices that the state uses would also
connect to those networks is that
is that something that you've looked
into we have not done that it it it
actually is um that would be a fairly
large undertaking and and um where it
goes beyond my uh my charge in in 21r
but um the I think it would depend on
the vendors and and I'm sure that
they're all looking at that now
um
so I I couldn't get go further than that
I haven't spent time on that particular
issue
representative spear
thank you I'm not so sure if I'm allowed
to
say this
would you believe oh would you believe
I looked at the FCC website and they are
definitely squashing it
anything that's coming from China to
deal with 5G that has any kind of
criteria that they're worried about
sending data back or whatever they've
stopped it and the FCC specifically
thank you
would you believe
you have to ask him yeah I think the
question would be has already there been
some right that made its way into is it
isn't it true yes
okay great thank you all right thank you
okay
nice
you see the this is right here sponsor
arrive yes
and he will fill out a pink card
my name is representative Terry Roy I
represent Rockingham 31 uh the towns of
Deerfield Candia Chester and Auburn and
um I understand you've heard some
testimony on this bill already from the
state I picked up a little bit at the
end of it there and I'm I'm very pleased
to see that they seem to be um beginning
to take a look at this
um having said that I heard executive
branch I didn't hear anything about the
judicial branch or any of the other
parts of government including our own
if the committee's decision is to say
let them handle it I would ask you to
make sure that you look into the fact
that this is this is pervasive across
all branches of government
and
this puts some teeth in it I didn't hear
anything about a penalty if a company
comes in and tries to bid to another
company into another company through a
shell game
and if they get caught as far as I heard
they're they're banned if they if they
get caught but this adds teeth to the a
company a U.S company that tries to
front for uh the Chinese government and
that has been happening in the states as
well
um it's it's everywhere it's very
difficult to track and keep up with in
real time
um so we're always playing catch-up I
feel like this bill would put some teeth
in it from the front and make companies
think twice about doing business with
the Chinese company and then proffering
themselves as a supplier to the state of
New Hampshire or any of its branches
um
having said that I'm open to any
questions I think you've heard the
technical aspects and I don't want to
have to repeat what was already
testified to
yeah so what we heard was that the the
governor has an order
and does affect all elements of
government
in just judicial branch as well
everybody I mean theoretically it's it's
uh across all across
executive branch executive branch okay
um and it's Dynamic and sense that it
can be rolling so things can come and go
and it's part of reaching
that's what we've heard so far so it
does just cover the executive branch or
all branches all all of the executive
branch okay so that still leaves the
judicial branch and the legislature or
other branches that are open to um to
purchasing this type of stuff so I would
only ask that if if
there's still questions that you at
least retain it and take a look to make
sure that there's a comprehensive plan
and we just don't throw it away and say
well the governor's on this
um right well we'll do our homework on
that but I would I would say at the end
of the day everything that's being
purchased has to go through executive
Council
so
um
so uh yeah so we will make sure that
this that Governor's order is effective
everywhere
any questions for me
we do represent them below we just have
a question about
um just drafting this bill did you
consult with the Department of I.T
The Who Department of I.T yeah
um no I did not um they um this bill
came out before I drafted this before
they came out with that executive order
okay
all right thank you and
representative uh thank you
um isn't there something like this on a
federal level
there there is and there isn't um they
it they put something out on a federal
level
um that wasn't broad or and it only
handled that they can't mandate what
states do so they can't tell States you
won't do business with this company so
technically it's not illegal to do
business with a Chinese company they
advise you you probably shouldn't
um so they on the federal level they say
we're not going to but the states are
kind of on their own in a kind of wild
west thing so the model legislation came
from the association of state
governments so they are recommending
that the member states actually take
action on their own at this point just
to make sure that they're not being left
on their own
you're welcome thank you
any other questions from the committee
members seeing none thank you thank you
get back to your committee
uh chair will call on Lily Tang Williams
who's in support of the bill
all right
yeah thank you actually I come here to
support other two bills but I heard
about this bill I look at the bill very
quickly and I will show my support for
this bill because I have a special
background I was born in communist China
I lived there for 24 years under the
iron Fest of China's Communist party and
I went to law school and my business
right now one of the home business I
have is actually the
expert witness I can go to court to
testify based on my personal background
experience life in China and on anything
related to Chinese business government
and the practices so this bill
is good because I know that some other
people might not know especially
business community that the Communist
Party of China is very clever very
shrewd to package their companies and
also their messages to the world to be
friendly to China and to think China is
somehow free market a little bit
framework economy
but I would just want to share with you
China's economy is totally
one-party control
some companies are registered as private
companies
but under the China's national security
law that applies to Hong Kong also that
means that anything they want from a
private company
they got to have it
and lots of former China's officials
inside the party
they go to sit on the board and become
owners of those so-called China private
companies you know what happened to
Alibaba if you are truly private company
dare to criticize a party they're going
to force you out
you know leave your company you funded
and going hide out overseas
and I know lots of self-employed Chinese
small business owners
I feel sympathetic toward them when
they're trying to do business under the
one party rule
but they have to comply with all their
National Security laws whatever data
they want whatever technology they want
or in the name of National Security you
gotta comply or you lose license to
exist
and I have friends who come to this
country as a political Refuge because
the local government trying to
steal their money destroy their
companies and they had to grab whatever
they have left and run into this country
so
and even where I come to New Hampshire
in 2019 I have been American citizen
since 1995.
and
because I speak up here against CCP I
was a threatened put on Blacklist cannot
go home to visit my family and friends
in China since 2019.
the recently discovered me is by some
social media posts on Facebook talk
about how much I love America I come
here with nothing I'm living American
Dream it's not even political but they
come to my social media thread me and my
family to say if you go back to China
oh you better not your wanted criminals
by telling the truth
but I feel it's my American Citizen's
duty to tell the truth to educate the
public for who they are what the true
color of China's Communist party and
what they portray to the world to the
Western countries
lots of them are lies
and they even hire social media
influencers to tell their lies they
think American people are naive about
China they romance in the Middle Kingdom
and just what they did for past 40 years
when China started opened up I support
the economical open up I support the
decentralization of the economy but
China today is going backward under the
dictatorship of Xi Jinping he is a
maoist
and he wants to tell the world we are
going to be number one by 2049 he's a
China drawing it's not Chinese people's
dream Chinese people are their biggest
with victims of their regime ruthless my
friends who in the law school with me in
Shanghai were locked down their homes
for 10 weeks starving could not go out
of their apartment doors were welded by
the iron bars
and that's why we had students going out
people going out for the white paper
protest silence they protest why they
hold a piece of white paper and smaller
than this one because they say we have
not to say but we cannot see it because
we will get locked up so we just stand
up there hold piece of paper quietly
protest because they thought there's a
zero Kobe lockdown is going to make them
and not to be dead anyway they might
just protest so now they just got rid of
that which is good right right but then
the collapse of medicine the health care
so people are dying and they don't even
tell the world
how many people are infected how many
people died
and their numbers are totally lying
so I would support our state
build like this and we have to be very
careful whenever we deal with anybody
related to a Chinese government for
example Confucius Institute was in state
of New Hampshire on campus of unh for so
many years founded by Chinese government
funded by the state Council under the
Han ban Chinese language Department
they were here send the teachers send
the money here to make China look good
they did teach language it did teach
culture which are all wonderful part but
what else they teach or they're not
allowed to teach not allowed to answer
student questions Honestly by their
teachers you don't know
that's what I'm saying they are very
very short we cannot be like if I'm in
New Hampshire now and whenever you deal
with Chinese government or companies if
you need my help I offer my service and
I offered to testify I speak Mandarin
Chinese I'm still trying to learn
English
and because it's just not my first
language but but I love this country I
love our state so I am you know offering
my own service if you have any more
questions please feel free to contact me
and thank you very much and Happy
Chinese New Year
this is yeah our Chinese New Year goes
from January 22nd all the way to
February 5th it's 15 days celebration
and this is a year of rabbit So Good
Year it's a love pensions prosperity and
Longevity so wish you all happy New Year
oh I'm still here for questions sorry
uh does anybody have any questions no
yes representative
um you're representing yourself you say
but what business do you own do you own
a business now yes and uh I'm a very
blessed in this country I come here with
nothing 100 in my pocket could not speak
English and the first day I met my
husband in Austin Texas going to
graduate school there and
get married raise three wonderful
children and work will work until I got
layoff year of 2000 I said hey here's my
opportunity to start my own business so
because I have low degree in China and
the truly bilingual now I hope and so I
started my business to do Consulting and
to um but that was not profitable for
eight years and later we got into
residential real estate so now my
husband took early retirement we managed
our rental properties I'm also
professional speaker and and expert
witness I can go to work on either a
Prosecuting side or defense side and go
to court to testify and so I have three
home business I have flexibility and for
the most time I'm really focused on you
know like how I can educate people about
China because I don't want this country
become like China but if the China
becomes number one
powerful country in the world like Xi
Jinping by 2049 I'm really worried about
my three children's Futures like I live
under their iron fist I don't want
anybody ever live under their hair fast
so that's my straight home business I
hope that's helpful thank you
great thank you very much thank you
uh chair will call and uh representative
Mike Belzer
thank you
yeah
I'm sorry are we all set with hb86
okay sorry close the hearing anything oh
yeah I wasn't paying attention
okay so uh
we are now about to do 225 okay
foreign
good afternoon chairman hunt members of
the committee
I am here to introduce House Bill 225
which is my bill about currency
and it says privacy rights but it's
actually a bit broader than that it
speaks generally to the rights of
Americans and New Hampshire citizens
now
you will
if you're familiar if you've been
following the news and following current
events you'll be familiar with the
concept of a central bank digital
currency
now what this is is effectively
a this is not the dollar not the dollar
as we know it is not the same currency
it would be a whole new fresh currency
that would be rolled out by the federal
government by the Federal Reserve
that would have no physical presence it
would be 100 digital and therefore be
programmed so it's essentially it's a
computer program
now there are ways to do this sort of
thing that are perfectly fine and then
there are ways to do this sort of thing
that are very troubling some of the
material I've passed around will
demonstrate uh how China has utilized
this exact same sort of Technology
um and unfortunately what we've seen and
what we've heard from some of the
members of the Federal Reserve is that
they intend to pursue a Direction with
their Central Bank digital currency that
is more akin to China than for instance
Bitcoin
um now I didn't specifically bring up
and mention uh Central Bank digital
currency in this bill for the very
simple reason that I don't necessarily
have a problem with a central bank
digital currency I have a problem with
the elements of a currency that would be
detrimental to individual rights so
let's talk about what some of those
problems could be
uh first of all we have privacy rights
right we don't necessarily want the
government knowing every time we buy a
sandwich or go to the store to pick up
feminine products or whatever we're
doing
the government does not need to know
that but with the Central Bank digital
currency there could be systems in place
allowing such information to be real
time available to the government or to
their Partners such as the Federal
Reserve or the big Banks
they can also program this currency to
prohibit certain types of transactions
or to only be allowable for certain
kinds of transactions
uh for instance to go to China again
they utilize this kind of technology and
they it's they will attach it to a
social credit score
and if you've said something not real
nice about the government of China or if
you've done something they don't like or
didn't do something they would you like
you to do they might just decide that
you don't get to buy lunch today or you
don't get any money deposit into your
account this week or you can't get on
the bus to go to work or wherever this
is the kind of power that can be
achieved through a centralized
digitalized program that is a central
bank digital currency
um
let's see have I missed anything here uh
also uh expiration dates this is another
thing that has been done as well as as
well as programming certain types of
inflation that are not
um not in line with good market
economics
um such as deciding all of a sudden
they're going to increase the amount of
currency in circulation but not increase
your share of that currency thereby
causing an inflation that devalues the
currency you hold these are the kind of
things that I believe we should be
trying to prohibit now the the timing of
this bill is quite important you'll see
from one of the handouts that I had go
around that the Federal Reserve has
already partnered with the New York fed
and big Banks to roll out a pilot
program of this in New York so this is
not something that's theoretical or
something that's coming down the road
it's already here and they're on the
verge of being able to launch this on a
nationwide scale my concern is it could
even happen this year at the earliest
um this would be horribly detrimental to
the rights of New Hampshire citizens
regardless of the intent of Any Given
Administration
the next one could be totalitarian and
they could come in and they could decide
to use the technology to turn America
into New Hampshire into an open-air
prison much like China is that's not
something we can we can tolerate here
um on that I'd be happy to take any
questions
representative spear
thank you I went on the Federal Reserve
website they said that uh one of the
Prime issues that they have is to
maintain privacy and that executive
order says that they will maintain
privacy
I would like uh okay okay so that my
question is
I've done a lot of looking into this
and so
my question is since this is very
hypothetical everything you talk about
is very hypothetical has not happened
yet
they've been talking and privacy is like
number one issue
they've been talking about how they
might Implement they haven't implemented
anything and in fact the Federal Reserve
says they what they don't want to move
unless they have agreement from Congress
Congress already has several bills in
place or working through the Congress
that would ensure privacy that whatever
Federal Reserve implements has to have
privacy as their top top priority
my question is should should somehow
Congress
falls on its face and the Federal
Reserve turns out to fall on its face
and they issue a currency a digital
currency that is
uh not private
this state currently gets 5 billion
dollars a year that's B with a B from
both Medicare and Social Security just
those two Services alone this law would
say people those five billion dollars
cannot come into this state
that the total is about a hundred and
it's about 50 of the population would
not get their Social Security checks nor
would
they get their net nor would their
Medicare get paid for
is that what you envisioning happening
with this in the hypothetical case where
Congress and the FEDS fall on their face
I I think I could pull a couple
questions out of that to the answer the
first one as far as the hypotheticality
of the of the question the privacy
issues I believe there is a readily
available quote you can look it up
online from Jerome Powell from the FED
making clear that the the Central Bank
digital currency they have worked on is
not anonymous
so that is that's something that's
that's out there you you can find that
um as far as the rest of the question
goes we're getting into some details
there and I I don't need to go into
details all I can say is you cannot put
a dollar amount on freedom
okay
representative
um thank you very much if I just look at
the situation that we're in now
um credit cards
um phone all of that could be traced I
mean what is so different about this
that the government can't go into my
credit card account and say he can't buy
lunch today or this and that and you
that that guy that murdered those kids
in in Idaho uh is that what it was uh
the college kids yeah Idaho and they
traced him with his all the blips of his
phone
um so I it seems to me that everything
you're you're talking about now is
already available to to a perverse
government that wanted to use it I don't
see that this really is that much more
extreme thank you representative so that
brings up a very good question and I
think there's some Nuance that needs to
be teased out a little bit so first of
all this bill only addresses things that
are inherent to a currency
meaning for instance you have a dollar
bill you go into a store you spend a
dollar bill
that's a private transaction but if you
decide to use your credit card well
that's a mechanism that is not inherent
to the currency and that kind of
information can be traced the government
you'll find out if they have a warrant
to find out what happened
and that's all that's all good and fine
what I'm talking about with this bill is
things that are inherent to the currency
so in other words the currency itself
would have to have a built-in mechanism
to actually provide this information to
the government or the government
Partners fed or whatever
um automatically not through some
secondary architecture that exists
if that does that answer your question
well I'm still wouldn't the government
uh under current circumstances need to
need a a warrant to get in to see that
uh under current circumstances yes but
with a with a cbdb they would not
why wouldn't they still need a warrant
to look at that information because a
non-anonymous cbdb would have a would
have a mechanism in place that makes
this information
readily available possibly even in a
real-time manner
I could compare it to all of these other
programs we've heard about as of late
um where the federal government has been
looking into other things that they
might maybe they shouldn't be looking
into but when you add the technology to
these sort of
to these sort of things it becomes much
easier
for them to create mechanisms that
automatically
allow them to look into private parts of
people's lives and that's all this
addresses it doesn't address it doesn't
say they can't get a warrant for
information there's nothing wrong with
that
all right uh John stepped out of the
room for singing uh I don't know who had
their hand up first I'll go to
representative Sullivan
see uh you just said that there's no
price for freedom but
this essentially takes away the freedom
of people who may want to participate in
something that perhaps is in some way
more valuable as they deem so if for
example this becomes some sort of
standard if they have this new currency
that's run by the fed and I find it to
be super convenient I'm willing to
accept a little bit of loss of privacy
you're now saying as a New Hampshire
resident I would not be allowed to do
that does that not take away some
freedom of choice that no you're you're
not exactly wrong about that and I've
actually I've heard some similar things
from what you might consider sort of
libertarian anarchists who would make
the argument that by restricting a
person's individual freedom to use a
potentially tyrannical Central Bank
digital currency you're infringing on
their freedom but we have to actually
weigh that as it as a government and
having the duty to protect our citizens
against the actual potential of this
technology to truly create a unfree 1984
or type society and
yes we do have to balance that little
bit of that little bit of give and take
there
other questions representative
sorry point of clarification you use the
phrase cbdb what is that what does that
stand I'm sorry cbdc Central Bank
digital currency okay and then to go
back to representative spire's earlier
question
would it and and you're the statement
you just made
is it possible for someone under your
bill living in New Hampshire to accept
their Social Security payments
or they're they're simply opted they
have to opt out there's a mechanical
issue which I'm not clear on here that's
thank you for that question so just to
clarify just to be very clear and I I
maybe I shouldn't use the term cbdc
um end this bill side by side because
they're not exactly the same thing so a
cbdc that does not violate the
provisions of this bill that are
designed to protect the individual
liberties of persons
um would be fine it would not be
disallowed but if they did decide to
make the one that was inherently
compromising privacy rights inherently
programmable to prevent certain
transactions
um then uh they to your specific
question whether or not it could be sent
to their bank account
that's a little bit of a gray area maybe
maybe not but it does Clearly say it
wouldn't not you could not use it for
any Dez public or private in the state
of New Hampshire
whether or not the federal government
putting that into a bank account counts
exactly against that that's a little bit
of a gray area
but it's something that I gotta be
honest I'm not particularly concerned
about because this this bill is about
protecting Liberty of the people and
they can design a cbdc that doesn't have
these problems there's a bunch of
current crypto that doesn't have these
problems
uh representative uh Gibbs please thank
you
um you mentioned uh the workings of a
central bank digital currency in
comparison to the workings of Bitcoin my
question is would you trust whoever it
is and I don't think we know honestly
whoever it is who runs Bitcoin more than
you would trust the Federal Reserve Bank
and if so why
well the way I understand it and I'm not
an absolute expert on bitcoin but nobody
actually runs Bitcoin it's a it's a it's
a program where you kind of store this
token on a hard drive somewhere
including possibly your own so you could
be your own you know sort of Banker in
that manner but what I trust them more
than this than the Federal Reserve
ah
I'm not sure there's a whole lot of
people that I wouldn't trust more than
the Federal Reserve given the way
they've handled currency
further inquiry
further inquiry thank you
um
how do we know that there's no
individual who runs Bitcoin I understand
that there are computers all over the
world uh apparently churning out
Bitcoins in some way that I don't
understand either but someone set up
those computers so how do we know there
isn't
someone or some group or some company
that runs Bitcoin uh thank you I so
again my understanding is there is a
fixed number of Bitcoin in the world and
that doesn't increase
um I believe it's just a program that
exists
um but as far as how can we be sure
somebody isn't running that behind the
scenes
I I don't exactly know how to answer
that question I think we're getting into
the weeds discussing uh Bitcoin there's
a lot of different currencies we could
be discussing but let's go back to the
bill uh
representative Herbert
did you have a question yes I I um my
question well I've got about three of
them but uh
if the Federal Reserve decided to become
or uh have a digital currency why
couldn't it be the dollar
well that that's more of a policy
question than a technical question uh
obviously they have in many ways
digitized the dollar
um that that does exist as a thing to a
limited degree anyway but I believe the
point of making essential Bank digital
currency is actually to have a different
currency that would be a policy
directive more than a technical thing
all right I think so they could make the
Federal Reserve credit theoretically
um say we're going to have a digital
currency it is the dollar it does uh it
does provide us with uh a digital dollar
to speed up settlement because that
apparently is a is a Advantage
um
so um
the other uh
I'm assuming when you say the word
autonomous
you are referring to the cryptocurrency
ecology
I'm sorry can you repeat that
when you say the word autonomous
autonomous then I'm it sounds to me as
though you're referring to the
cryptocurrency what I call the Ecology
of the cryptocurrency it's a
peer-to-peer uh very uh secure type of
uh
uh uh it's I'm sorry can you point me
exactly what reference you're making as
far as autonomous is that in the bill
what do we I'm trying to get it well I
haven't read all the all your bill okay
but you have made some things and I have
questions about them number one you
answered because the dollar could in
in theory I believe it could be in
theory yes
um the uh when you use the word
autonomous I'm I'm not quite sure
exactly what you mean by that
I use the word several times in your I
don't remember you saying the word but
maybe you did I I'm sorry I I don't
actually recall if I used it or what
context I use it in well my
understanding would be that that is the
cryptocurrent one of the
cryptocurrencies characteristics oh I
believe I I think I know so I I may have
suggested that the that the currency
itself was okay
um not was was decentralized it was not
um not like oh being as far as Bitcoin
anyway not being overseen by some person
or entity but rather
unless you actually give it to a person
energy to oversee it is my understanding
yeah I mean well crypto is
decentralized uh finance and I get that
um
my third question
is that the constitution gives a
monopoly over the currency to Congress
yes so
my concern would one of my one of my
concerns would be if a secondary another
currency was legitimized
in concert with the dollar I mean all of
these things could happen
um my my concern at that point would be
who's going to control the money supply
of the dollar and I I asked that
question because whoever does controls
the nation no
I believe your question is who controls
the the dollar itself who controls the
money supply you're asking or you're I
think one of your goals is to have
cryptocurrency
be part of the money supply
I I have no such goal in here my only
goal is to prevent the rollout of a
certain type of digital currency that
would be horribly detrimental to the
individual liberties of people should
they decide to flip that switch and and
not take it in a nice Direction what
model are you using
okay I'm not sure we'll talk offline
with the rest of the uh representative
spear
I answer to both thank you
I want to get back to my original
statement
there are bills in Congress right now
from a whole pot load of states
that are telling the federal that are
limiting the federal reserve's ability
to use account based
currency as opposed to token-based
currency and some hybrid thereof
token based being totally Anonymous but
very dangerous
account based being very unanonymous and
not what people want those laws are
there
shouldn't this be or they're in the
process this is a Federal Reserve
situation
it hasn't happened yet don't know if
it's another question representative is
there a question in there okay yeah
there is there is a question why my
question is
why is this even being brought to the
state level when it's in fact a federal
level issue and should be handled at the
federal level and they are working on it
at the federal level why are you
bringing it to the state uh thank you
for that question I am bringing it to
the state because the the state is not
in all things subservient to the federal
government we have the authority to
create a conflict with the federal
government where there is constitutional
issues involved they have coinage
authority that's absolutely true but the
federal government does not have the
authority to violate citizens Liberties
through coinage and my intention and my
hope is that by bringing such a bill
having it passed it will put our state
into a position to have the courts take
a look at this issue and hopefully
decide that such a currency that would
violate the rights of citizens is an
unconstitutional matter
see you avoided avoided the
cryptocurrency question all right thank
you representative Gibbs question
yes thank you
um
I used the term Bitcoin
um a few minutes ago as an example
representative Roy because you had
referenced Bitcoin but it was really
intended to be a broader question which
is how do we know that we can or should
have any trust in the people who set up
the computer programs that are producing
cryptocurrency of any kind so that's an
unrelated question to what we're talking
about I know it might not seem like it
but it really is and uh that's a rabbit
hole that would take an hour
conversation so
if you don't mind if I could just real
briefly I would I would I would state
that that is something of an
epistemological question trying to seek
out how do we ultimately find knowledge
about something and it's the same answer
to that as it would be to anything else
you would have to investigate it go down
those rabbit holes and then do you
really know the answer at the end I mean
it's a
all right well that's a good statement
all right thank you and I'll just have
my own personal would you believe uh the
governor signed an executive order first
one last year cryptocurrency commission
we had almost a Year's worth of meetings
we issued a report and in that report is
a lot of definitions that are worth
reading over one of those definitions is
Central Bank digital currency with some
hyperlinks and then I made a personal
statement in the appendix about the
Central Bank digital currencies uh it
might be interesting to read would you
believe and a few of the commission
members signed off on that statement so
that might be something to help with
background before we get into the
subcommittee I'll send a link to the
committee all right any other questions
okay
all right thank you for your testimony
thank you Mr chair members
and next up we'll have representative
hole and he supports the bill
we're still on 225. yes we are still in
houseville 225. representative whole
um representing the towns of Dunbarton
hooks at Allentown and epsom now known
as Merrimack 27.
testifying in favor of House Bill 225
um for a little bit of History I want to
start back at the Constitutional
Amendment that was adopted in 2018 the
question was and I quote are you in
favor of amending part first of the
Constitution by inserting after article
2A new article to read as follows
article 2B right to privacy an
individual's right to live free from
government intrusion in private and
personal information is natural
essential and inherent end quote
that was adopted by 81 percent of the
people who voted in 2018.
that's not a partisan issue that is an
overwhelming response in fact I've
looked at the Constitutional Amendments
over the last several decades and this
is one of the ones with the highest
approval rating
I say that because we all grew up in a
society
where our transactions were Anonymous
for those who had dollar bills when we
went to the grocery store and bought
eggs or milk okay and we handed over a
five dollar bill that was an anonymous
transaction
that is how we came to as a society over
the over decades right even more so when
they were stamped coins without serial
numbers on them
when the Federal Reserve Reserve started
putting serial numbers it became a
little bit more traceable when you go to
the bank today and you ask for a stack
of 20s or if those who can afford for
larger denomination bills ask for them
they come out of a magic money machine
they say that a little bit
tongue-in-cheek but there is a machine
that counts the money but it also in
likely also records the serial numbers
of every one of those bills that's
handed over to you it is possible to do
that it is not hard with optical
character recognition in real time to
scan an entire stack of bills and know
exactly what serial numbers are being
handed out that's not difficult with our
modern technology
this bill is forward-looking it is
trying to preserve what we've lived with
and grown with and the society we've
built that has worked so well for the
decades in the past in in an era where
all the transactions are online in real
time every day
customers have the choice today do they
want to go buy something with their Visa
card which is a recorded transaction by
a private agency okay that is accessible
potentially to the banks as well as the
government
or do they want to pay with cash
and if they really are you flagging me
down okay or or if they really want it
to be private it's coins not even dollar
bills but that is that record there is
no record of that transaction
the goal of this bill and if the
language needs tweaks I would gladly
work on it is to make sure we preserve
that status quo going forward
because
it really isn't government's business
whether you bought a dozen eggs or you
you splurged at the eight dollars for
the 18 eggs
um my point is we should at least make
sure we have the protections for our the
privacy of our citizens given that the
citizens overwhelmingly just a few years
ago supported a constitutional amendment
regarding privacy
secondly there was a comment made about
the U.S Constitution about
coining money and I want to make sure
that we're we're clear part first
article sorry
section one article eight
specifies that the federal government
and I quote
um where is it
um two coin money regulate the value
thereof and and a foreign coin and fix
the standard and weights and measures
unquote
it doesn't give exclusive Authority it
just says it can and there is a
fundamental difference it doesn't
prohibit other groups from doing it in
this section with that I'll close my
testimony
and if there's any questions I'll take
them or I'll go back to my questions
Witness
all right seeing none thank you thank
you representative hole
and next we'll call Representative
sellers uh supports the bill and asks
for one minute
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
for letting me speak for a couple
actually about a minute I said that song
and I really need
uh just give an idea and just Bitcoin in
general just in case you're not aware
when you when you actually own Bitcoin
you're your own bank and I use Bitcoin
Loosely meaning all types of crypto
coins you are the bank
you lose it it's gone it's just an idea
so looking at this bill it says it says
no currency and then it's trying to
describe the currency all right at that
point and what they're trying to do is
making sure we keep our privacy that's
all this bill is really trying to do to
keep our privacy I just looked on the 20
bill I have in my pocket and it says for
a it's a no for tender for a public or
private transactions so we can use the
cash dollar bill right now for a private
transaction all right if my neighbor kid
breaks my yard I can give them twenty
dollars it's a private transaction well
if a cryptocurrency comes up or some
type of other currency are tangible what
it might be I want to be able to use
that to pay my kid my next-door neighbor
kit to break my yard it could be still a
private transaction we don't want to
lose that and I think that's what we're
trying to do here is is they're trying
to protect the citizens of New Hampshire
and we want to make sure that's
protected that's all we're doing and
this is not Republican a Democrat this
is everyone I think everybody from time
to time has some things they do they
want to keep private all right so that's
what we're trying to do is keep things
private thank you
thank you for that succinct testimony
any questions
all right seeing done
thank you
is there a question I just wanted to
representative application so I think
that you stated it you're not against
the technology but you want to make sure
the Privacy aspect is
supported and adhered to in New
Hampshire
uh I'd like to say I'm against the
technology too but it's there's no
stopping it it's it's it's coming a some
type of cashless Society is coming so
therefore I just want if we can let's
keep it private as long as we can in New
Hampshire and then follow up real quick
so you're seeing that this is eventually
a cash replacement
proposal eventually at the federal level
if you know
from all I know and what's coming down
the pike yes
thank you and Representative Vincent
thank you very much Mr chairman I
stepped out for a minute I apologize too
many meetings and too many people to
make happy you'll keep happy yeah
however and if you if you cover this I
apologize to the committee but um a
quick quick question here is
is it dangerous to play this game uh
with what we currently have
meaning uh we already have a currency in
place if we introduce another currency
uh are we playing with fire so to speak
quick answer if you can
foreign
currency is coming if it's government or
whoever controls it I'm not sure who it
is
it's it's coming it's just the the whole
point of think of this bill is we still
want to be able to have to try to have
private transactions that's the whole
key here is there's some way if they
want to go digital or crypto or any
other type of currency they want to do
is whatever it is in the future we don't
want to each one of us have an account
we want to make sure each one of us are
individuals and keep our information
private if we want to
thank you
all right okay question from uh you have
a would you believe representative
just hit your button there
um would you believe
that the
um today in the news
there is a item that about four and a
half billion dollars in crypto
have been lost
or stolen
so and this is I know it doesn't sound
like it but that's an unrelated topic
it's it's it's tangential but it's not I
hear you're talking about something else
we end up with dollars okay so and as a
result and this is a very secretive
system when you want to launder money
or you want to hide your tax cheat you
want to hide money you want an anonymity
and that's the reason why
there is a pushback when you say
freedom and you attach it to
a lot of stuff but freedom from
freedom from being cut
by doing something illegal is something
apparently I when I hear that it's
almost like this is this is the danger
is like you I think you're you're
wandering into territory that is uh
um
right now all uh theoretical
and so we're constantly reminded that it
is it is would you believe it is almost
or it's been proven it's almost
impossible
to hide
forever whatever you're doing
and um uh so I have I have a lot of
skepticism
would you believe in would you be
replacing a dollar so yes I I believe
you can't hide everything that is
impossible but we're always going to
have that element out there that is
trying to do something wrong and trying
to get you know to hide their money for
one reason or another but we also we
have a lot of citizens that just want to
have their privacy so and that's what
we're trying to do in New Hampshire yeah
we I don't want to see money laundering
anything like that it's not necessary
but you have that element out there and
until they get caught you know we have
them
okay all right thank you very much for
your testimony we have two cards left
for this thank you thank you
um
I'll call uh Joel Joel Venezuela and ask
for 10 minutes maybe a little shorter
than that
just turn on your mic there hit that
button there you go hey good afternoon
and thank you very much for the
opportunity to provide testimony today
um I do believe that this bill raises an
important issue and I'm in general
support of of the uh the push to
preserve privacy however I do think that
the language of the bill might
unintentionally cause some legal
complications for other forms of of
digital assets such as cryptocurrencies
and um in particular
um right here no currency whether
tangible digital or otherwise which
inherently compromises privacy by
provision of transaction or usage
details to any government agency or
partner
now most decentralized digital assets
run on public ledgers public blockchains
and they tend to be pseudonymous meaning
they don't necessarily they aren't
always tied to a physical identity
except uh
they still are all completely public and
so for example if you make a payment and
that's tied to your public key or public
address then that could be considered
now that is provisioning
data to a government entity and
compromising privacy and this could be
used to apply to just about every
digital currency or digital asset out
there including Bitcoin and ethereum of
course and it could of course end up
providing a chilling effect to
businesses seeking to do business in the
state of New Hampshire and decreasing
the New Hampshire Advantage it's so
while I do support the general thrust of
the bill to preserve individual privacy
in finances I do think that there at
least needs to be some rewording in
exactly the way this is written to not
necessarily
Encompass something that would ban an
entire you know as of now perfectly
legal sector from doing business in New
Hampshire
and I'd be happy to answer any of
specific questions about this
Mr chair
could we get a name I don't have a
question and and a town and organization
is there yeah I'm Joelle Valenzuela I'm
a crypto and uh blockchain consultant
from Somersworth thank you
what's the word pseudonymous mean what's
yes apologies for that it's
it's um similar to so Anonymous means no
one knows who you are pseudonymous means
everyone knows who you are through
pseudonym
so for example it just it would be you
know wait like for example if you have a
social media handle sometimes people
don't have those under their full name
but they're very well known under that
handle and that's what pseudonymous is
and so for example uh most popular
cryptocurrencies are completely public
and very easy to you know definitely
much more easy than the US dollar to
examine every single transaction out
there except that the ID
um identity behind everyone who uses
them is not always known of course this
is becoming increasingly more known as
there's they're more Associated to for
example certain financial institutions
I'm fine just another pseudonymous uh so
would I be correct in saying that an
illegal
drug cartel
could use a system
in have a pseudonymous name
and that would uh make it easier to get
dollars for it or Euros or anything like
that would pseudonymous be an attraction
to that kind of activity I personally
don't think so because uh at the state
of the way the technology is today uh
blockchain analytics companies have had
quite a good track record of working
with law enforcement and associating
individual transactions and individual
addresses especially across the more
popular networks of Bitcoin and ethereum
to individual identities especially at
entry and exit points into you know US
dollars for example so I don't really
see that as a significant issue
I'm I'm surprised actually
Joel just one more time for the record
you're representing yourself yes in
another company yes my company desk
Center LLC okay can you spell that
please d s c e n t r okay thank you any
other questions
um I have one if that's okay yes could
you explain the difference between
a dollar bill that is a piece of paper
that I put here and maybe the wind blows
it and it moves uh and maybe it doesn't
and electronic currency that's
programmable could you explain the
difference between those two things and
how it relates to the bill
might take a while to go through all the
particulars because there's a large Gulf
behind that but essentially the money
most of us use today could be considered
a central bank digital currency in that
it's issued by a central bank it is a
currency and it is digitally represented
a few few of us use the majority or all
of our transactions in paper cash and so
already there are digital ledgers
between Banks and other financial
institutions that do transmit the dollar
value between different accounts and so
uh when you go go to a one of the
challenges with the whole cbdc issue is
that it Still Remains extremely vague as
to what exactly specifics will kind of
constitute that and so as far as
programmable money
um there are certain uh blockchains
which can be used to sort of set to
preset certain conditions for usage and
as opposed to for example when you a
manual way whereas you call your bank
and your bank says you can't send to
this account we put a freeze on your
account because of this or whatever that
would be like a manual way and it is
possible to kind of automate some of
these things for example there's a a
token called usdc which is a US dollar
backed stablecoin which is on several
networks it's basically a representation
of US dollar that's backed one to one by
actual dollars in the bank somewhere and
in that are programmed some limitations
of where can be sent for example
um sanctioned addresses by the US
government are are there's a list of
these sanctioned addresses and
programmatically it just can't be sent
there so rather than a bank which then
would have to sort of manually figure
out where you can and can't send
something like this it's something like
this can just be kind of inherently
programmed into the the token
all right thank you and uh
representative post do you have a
question
yes thank you very much
um and thank you for being here today
it's very interesting but as you're
saying all of this in answer to
representative Ammon all I'm thinking of
is we already had that it's the credit
card I I sign up for a credit card they
give me twenty thousand dollars to play
with right I pay my bills with it then
that when when after I pay my bills and
I have to pay the credit card I log on
to my bank and pay it there put in my my
bank number and they take it never never
touch a dollar at all so would you say
that this is similar although it would
be a bank rather than a credit card
yes in this case it would be I suppose
similar mostly in my opinion again this
a lot of this is still rapidly
developing not only technology but also
policy across a wide variety of world
governments the cbdc concept
seems to focus more on trying to
consolidate and simplify payment rails
rather than to do something entirely
different now obviously that could be
completely untrue of a different country
cbdc or the Federal Reserve comes out
with something different next week that
ends up being different but mostly yeah
I would say this is on the whole nothing
new to a lot of the systems we have
today it would just be a an update and a
consolidation of the payment technology
behind it
follow up
thank you so with a credit card
um they track everything they do they
yeah I can look on my Facebook account
and it'll tell me just what I looked at
um on Amazon right yes how how would we
Preserve with this type of currency that
we aren't tracked on every little thing
so can I just jump in so your credit
card is a private company the cdbc would
be run by the government so you'd
basically be handing over all of your
transactional data every cup of coffee
you buy you'd be handing over that data
to the government and they would promise
to not spy on you or Snoop on you so
your credit card company
I I don't well I may not
um but a credit card company is a
private institution and we have we
currently have a private banking system
so if that helps explain it is that yes
all right let's we're going to move on
all right uh is that okay unless you
have something else to say no with just
my primary concern with this is just
that the language of the bill has a lot
of potential unintended consequences and
I'm
I'm happy to suggest a few okay
obviously I'm not a legislature
legislator but I'm happy to suggest a
few small edits that could possibly turn
it into a a direction where the original
intent is preserved and then can be
voted obviously yes or no at that stage
but that doesn't have these unintended
consequences so just for the record
you're opposed to the bill but you may
have suggestions for our subcommittee
which will happen in the next week or so
yes that's correct any other questions
uh representative spear
thank you I had mentioned before about
how in the wording that's current
they're currently there and should the
Federal Reserve
Implement a uh digital currency that is
not private which they said they don't
want to do but if they did
hypothetically
isn't do you see a problem with the
wording as it exists that people getting
their Medicare and their Social Security
payments
um potentially I guess we'd have to see
which form this kind of system ends up
taking but in general I
I'm in favor I personally do not favor
uh language which would tend to
I which could have the possibility of
banning or accidentally limiting or
Banning a wide variety of things I'd
rather I personally rather focus on
Banning Banning if that makes sense is
in not forcing people to use a certain
thing or not but once a lot of times
when you become a little bit too
sweeping with this kind of language you
could have a lot of unintended
consequences for example like that
all right representative Terry uh you
have spoken you have spoken uh of
unintended consequences what you believe
to be unintended consequences uh will
you be submitting uh formally submitting
your suggested tweaks changes to the
language to improve the bill to the
subject to the committee yes I can if
that is useful to the committee could we
ask him to do so yes yes uh please do
that the committee uh email address is
on the state's website thank you thank
you thank you all right thank you Mr
Venezuela thank you and the last stop we
have this is the last card for this bill
Lily Tang Williams
and Lily if you could uh you asked for
five to eight minutes if you could be
closer to five that would be great
that's good
well thank you for having me back and
this is a bill actually intend to come
here initially
um the China right now actually is
taking the word a leading rule in
developing digital and currency that is
a totally centralized and pushed down to
their citizens you know why they start
to do this because exactly
Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies they
saw them decentralized and Chinese
people were trying to invest in those
crypto this so that was a big threat to
their regime and the economy and the
political system so they banned Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies and they're
trying to develop their own digital un
since 2014 and of course I totally
understand why they're doing that
because that's unelected you know almost
indigen English like a legitimate
government people deny elect them and
they want to control the money they
don't want to citizens to transfer their
money to overseas to any other Market
they do to be threat to them
but what I want to warn people is that
but they are their tactics their
behaviors and their beliefs are now are
on equal word economical form website so
the other countries are saying oh that's
convenient that's efficient we should
learn from China we want to do our maybe
Global Central Bank in different
countries their digital currencies but
what they don't tell you is how Chinese
citizens are subject to completely
losing their civil liberties and privacy
I grew up in China I never had any in
privacy I mean it was alien concept to
me civil liberties and concept like that
but now with this digital currency they
are already pushing down to 10 percent
of population which is over 130 meaning
Chinese now are using digital Yen and
it's on their cell phone everything's
Transit is not on their cell phone based
on a QR code so they track every
transition you have there's a funny joke
a CCP official you know use that digital
currency on cell phone to pay for
prostitution next they got arrested
immediately like how stupid is that like
did you know they are tracking you every
move so so this is a potentially very
dangerous to our civil liberties in this
country if we allow central government
Federal Reserve to push it down on us
you know we can discuss the language to
improve the bill and all for that but I
just want to earn that it is a very
dangerous Potential Threat to our
privacy our rights that specified in the
U.S Constitution and in New Hampshire
Constitution and I still very very
mind-boggling why the world is learning
so much from my native country a China
communist party their behaviors
techniques tactics
and and the styles of controlling their
citizens we're all trying to get away
coming here to run away from that but
here I am testifying telling our stories
to say we don't want to learn from them
at all they have a completely different
ideologies Concepts they do not value
human lives and human privacy so I'm
here to support the bill by myself a
American citizen and by choice and I
hope that the bill can be improved that
way that you know we can get this voted
down thank you very much I'll be happy
to take your questions
okay any questions
okay I guess we're good thank you very
much thank you
and I don't see any other questions or
any other pink sheets uh would someone
grab the blue sheet
with someone yeah grab the blue sheet
this is uh 225
right and with that we'll close the
hearing of house bill 225.
just
okay on the blue sheet we've had uh six
people signed in on the blue sheet for
two two five
five or for the bill and one is neutral
so we'll open the hearing on House Bill
227 and we'll call
we'll call Rep
Bernardi uh to introduce the bill
good afternoon committee and I'm
representative JD Bernardi I represent
Rockingham 36 which is Hampton Falls
Kensington Southampton Newton and
Plaistow Southeast New Hampshire I'm
here to rise in support of House Bill
227 Fair access to financial services
the thrust of this bill is the financial
institutions and I'll just use Banks the
shorthand from now on
not deny a financial service unless a
person fails to meet traditional
quantitative impartial risk-based
standards established in advance so this
is your traditional financing criteria
what does this mean it means that you
cannot then add criteria like ESG d-i-j
or any other non-traditional
non-financial criteria as the basis of
making operational decisions in your
bank
why should we care
because currently banking industry is
adopting these kinds of criteria which
is inconsistent with traditional
Financial criteria
the largest organization doing this is
the U.N
Affiliated organization
it's part of the Glasgow Financial
Alliance for Net Zero
it's called The Net Zero banking
Alliance I have
um passed around a uh a sheet here
indicating
their membership in the United States
um
this is directly from their website
that's why it's printed the way it is I
could have made it look fancier but this
is their website so it's their data
125 Banks internationally in 41
countries representing 73 trillion
dollars in assets or 41 of global
banking assets
I've listed the U.S companies and you
see first Amalgamated Bank which most
probably don't know that's the bank of
all the trade unions AFL-CIO
Teamsters whatever
um then you see most of the major banks
in the in the U.S in fact the top six
Banks Bank of America is number two in
the U.S
Citibank number six JP Morgan Chase
number one Morgan Stanley number four
Goldman Sachs number five Wells Fargo
number three so the top six banks in the
United States have all signed on to
moving these criteria forward
well why do we care that they're
implementing ESG criteria
the results of these criteria are
essentially stopping or restricting
things like financing of coal oil and
gas
Citibank has dropped 100 percent of its
financing of coal
ninety percent of the exploration
production shipping pipelines activity
in the United States has been stopped
for oil and gas
by these Banks
what does this mean locally
your fuel oil your natural gas your LP
gas prices are all going to go up
because of shortened supplies and this
happened long before
the whole Ukraine situation started this
happened two years ago the initiation
the start of the rise of these prices
these criteria require restricting
financing of farming activities
internationally as well as the United
States
so in the United States
follow the news you see Bill Gates is
buying up massive stretches of farmland
and taking them out of production
you've seen major riots in Netherlands
Sri Lanka and Ghana and even Canada over
the control and loss of Farmland
production
you've seen restriction in financing of
firearms companies and ammunition
manufacturers
I'd like to give you a quote on how this
is all supposed to work by Brian
Moynihan who's the CEO of Bank of
America that number two company on the
list
take our 200 000 people
3 trillion balance sheet
60 billion of expenses you start aiming
that gun and you take that across all
these companies and it's huge it's
actually the operating companies that
will make the change happen and the
activities they force Downstream are
just unbelievable
now all six companies on this list have
similar kinds of quotes by their CEOs or
various Representatives
so not only are these companies adopting
ESG criteria for their own business as
Mr Moynihan is saying but also allowing
but also pushing them onto their
suppliers and their customers
so that they classify this as class one
class two and class three groups as they
push starting with themselves was number
one their suppliers is number two their
customer base is number three
they're also bringing these policies
into the trade associations they're
affiliated with Business Roundtable Bank
policy Institute Financial Services form
Chamber of Commerce
so you may ask how does this relate to
our New Hampshire Banks or New Hampshire
Credit Unions
well all these major banks have access
to the Federal Reserve whenever they
need it because of their massive size
but New Hampshire Banks New Hampshire
Credit Unions
they have access to these major Banks
that's their corresponding Bank
and as Mr Moynihan said we are going to
push these policies down into our supply
chain and into our customers so
if you looked at this sheet you saw a
little
annotation on the far right hand side
about having a link
so
The Net Zero banking Alliance had this
policy of of how they're going to push
these policies down and all these banks
are supposed to come up with their
published targets of how they're going
to implement this tasking and you see
their target dates for when they're
doing it so you see some of them
happened already last October many of
them happen this spring you're going to
see the first announcements by these
major Banks of how they're going to cram
these requirements down on their
customer base and on their supply chain
so if you like your gas stove
you like your gas dryer you like a gas
or diesel car truck
you like your firearms
you're going to have trouble in the
future financing these or getting access
to a bank that will work with you
this bill is just very very simple it
says we want to stick to the way we've
always done business there's traditional
rules of how you conduct business how
you assess a creditor how you assess
someone worthy to be a a client of your
bank yeah we're not we're going to work
with people that are in illegal
businesses we're not going to work with
people in illegal businesses we're going
to give loans for anyone who has the
assets and the and the credit worthiness
to pay them back all these are
traditional rules of financing and we're
not employing any other criteria d-e-i-j
ESG or whatever kind of additional
criteria they want to implement stick
with the tried and true that we've lived
with since the beginning of this country
if banks are allowed to collectively
decide to stop financing any group of
people or businesses they don't like
based on some ideological considerations
not true Financial concerns
then the elitist Bankers not you
are just are are deciding not you the
elected representative of the peoples
will will be deciding what's going on
and will and they will have total
control of our society they control all
the money and the flow of the money
they're controlling our society they
don't need to pass legislation to do it
so I view it as the responsibility this
legislature to be responsible to the
people's needs for setting public policy
nine other states are currently acting
on similar legislation North Dakota
South Dakota Wyoming Montana Georgia
Oklahoma Texas Utah and Arizona
I would also point out
that if you don't believe these ESG
criteria are being implemented then you
have a problem with our New Hampshire
attorney general because he is along
with 24 other attorney generals have
just sued the Department of Labor over
implementing ESG criteria in uh in our
traditional pension fund operations
so I strongly urge your decision to keep
us with traditional financing criteria
and be happy to answer any of your
questions
okay thank you so a lot of people have
their hand up I have a list in my head
we're going to go representative Herbert
Representative Vincent representative
batusic representative Gibbs and then
representative McAleer so we'll go in
that order
oh I'm sorry and
you'll be at the end sorry I uh
just two questions
um I'm a little puzzled by Net Zero
banking why do they call themselves Net
Zero banking I I've associate that with
zero interest Easy Money banking but Net
Zero must mean something else yes that
that Net Zero means we have no carbon by
the year 2050 in any of our our fuel
usage oh okay well all right that makes
sense to me but uh the other question is
these are all private corporations now I
understand they're powerful because of
their money and and their relationships
to governments probably
but I uh the thing that popped up uh to
me was I think something like this
occurred to break apartheid in South
Africa in other words suddenly uh there
was very little money coming into South
Africa for the The Mining and all that
kind of stuff because it was uh slave
labor and it was racist
so and it worked
even though they threw the most famous
black leader in jail for 20 some years
but so I understand the uh the
relationship ESG it's all about clean
air and
stuff like that uh and and I I
understand if you're in the coal
business or you're Chevron or or
otherwise that it would might put
pressure on you because the shares are
not getting bought and sold as as you
would like
uh but it's still I would be I would
rather have that circumstance done than
have the government
start to dictate what the private sector
can invest in that's what would you
believe would you believe but I thanks
for answering my Net Zero okay with
respect to South Africa that was an
international essentially boycott that
the various companies and some
governments uh got involved in
um that's not this circumstance this
circumstance is you're having
essentially the major
financial institutions and if you go to
that website there are it's the it's the
uh Global uh uh uh Financial uh Alliance
for Net Zero there are all six types of
financial institutions so it's it's the
uh not just Banks but any of the other
institutions the people that are
managing our our Pension funds and
whatnot all the groups associated with
that BlackRock uh Vanguard State Street
um all of them are signing on to this
program and saying this is how you have
to work that's how you have to live
that's not appropriate all we're saying
is if you want to do that fine as as
your little bank but announce it ahead
of time and if you're not going to do
that then you have to follow traditional
criteria
all right Representatives Vincent thank
you very much Mr chairman thanks a lot
for taking my question I just want to
let you know as I delivered this
question to you it's not coming from a
Democrat it's not coming from a
republican right now it's a neutral
party so I'm not picking sides either
way so what you're trying to say well no
I'm talking about in the question about
ready to deliver so what you're trying
to say is these Financial uh
institutions are trying to take over
because maybe some Representatives
somewhere Congress here might not like
uh they might not like the way that gun
control is or dirty uh type of energy
they don't you're trying to say that
they're actually trying to take over
what we're trying to do
is that what you're trying to say
because that's what it sounds like
you're saying yeah one of the roles of
ESG if you have the financial
institutions making all the rules that
everybody has to follow for all your
money is controlled ultimately by those
folks your options are cut off your
options are foreclosed yeah then they
have made the rules and you are
irrelevant
thank you
all right representative
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Bernardi isn't it true
that MasterCard right now is tracking
the gun dealers transactions
therefore making a registry of gun
owners
I believe they were whether they still
are or not because it has it has been
challenged and it has been made public
that this is going on and there's was a
great concern over it so I don't know if
they're still doing it but yes
there have been a MasterCard was
involved in that definitely
all right thank you I think I said
representative Gibbs next
thank you
um
question uh
if a bank in considering whether or not
to make a loan were to take into account
a company's record either in harming the
environment or in avoiding harming the
environment that we the people all have
to live in why would that be a bad thing
that they would take that into account
I think that decision that's a policy
decision that you folks should make
it's not a policy decision the bank
should make so if I'm if I'm uh run a
fuel oil company and I need to get a new
truck and I go to the bank and say I
want financing for my new fuel oil truck
I don't think that bank should have the
right to say I'm not going to give that
loan to you I think now if you as
legislators say that's going to be the
policy in New Hampshire we're going to
get rid of fuel oil then fine but it's
not it should not be the bank's decision
to do that okay one quick one further
inquiry thank you
um
so are you saying that we as a
legislature should tell private
businesses the standards that they
should use in the operation of their
businesses
so that is you have that role within the
limits of the Constitution
representative meckler
uh thank you very much
um I I have an investment background and
you're you're saying that these are
these old traditional ways of investment
we need to stick to that ways that
people that people invest have changed
all the time they're always modified I'm
sure you're familiar with BlackRock I'm
sure who's the CEO it's either Fink or
zinc or whatever
he makes a very very good case that this
is what they're doing investing in
companies that that have uh good ESG
scores they're doing that for financial
reasons they feel that that is a better
investment so for example let's suppose
we've got two companies that do business
along the Merrimack river and and one of
them is uh is polluting the Merrimack
river and and both of them go to the
bank and the bank says well wait a
minute these guys that are polluting the
river they're going to be in trouble
that is not a good investment therefore
we're not going to invest with them
we're going to invest with that other
company I believe that you're presenting
this as this is some sort of a boogeyman
going on here when it's not these people
these companies are investing for
financial reasons only and they just
feel that using this criteria excuse me
it gives it a better excuse me
excuse me that's a question that is a
question okay is is that not true that
they're investing for financial reasons
so if you're using ESG scores in your
adding those to your assessment of a A
party's credit worthiness uh that that's
what uh Larry think of BlackRock wants
to do
um
and that's what he says he does uh
I I will tell you that the evidence
shows that those Investments are nine
percent less
worthy in their in their rate of return
than people that use traditional
investment strategy nine percent
therefore it's appropriate to stick to
traditional criteria now with respect to
your comment about a polluter versus a
non-polluter okay now A Bank evaluating
that criteria is going to say
what is your credit worthiness and your
ability to pay and if you are being
violative of laws and a polluter you are
likely to have lawsuits brought against
you by environmental agencies and your
credit worthiness is going to be less so
yes indeed a bank can look at that kind
of criteria but that's not what this is
talking about what you said is exactly
my point yeah let's let's just calm down
the room a little bit because I think
we're getting worked up uh you have
another question representative
uh no I'll I'll leave it there thank you
thank you yes
yes okay my bill right now is dealing
with just the banking industry I have a
parallel bill it deals with the
investing Community it's not heard in
this committee I'm going to keep things
moving here uh we had uh
who was next I can't remember
anyway
would you like to go representative
thank you my question is this do you
feel that a private company
um has the right to develop their own
mission statement and their own set of
values which most most large
corporations do
all companies have their own mission
statements and whatnot exactly follow up
please follow so if that's true and
let's say I open let's say I open a bank
here or we open a bank here in New
Hampshire and part of our value
statement is that we are going to
predict the environment here in New
Hampshire
why can't we have policies in terms of
our our lending that reflect our our
company values to protect that why is
that a problem
I don't think it's a problem but the
question is how do you define protecting
the environment and I don't and and
there's where the the issue lies and
that that becomes a public policy issue
in many in in many of these cases and
once you get to the point where
all the institutions I have that point
of view and there are no other options
available because
as I pointed out the top six banks in
the United States and right now 41
percent of all the institutional capital
in the world that's in the banking
industry says you were going to do this
you are foreclosing the options for
other opportunities
okay thank you uh we'll go
representative facton
representative decton would you do you
have a question so
the the problem with this that this is
probably trying to prevent and is this
is actually discrimination because when
you are lending to someone based on a
Criterion
this is the question is am I corrected
my understanding you are correct that
this is a just really a discrimination
issue so 45 years ago I could have a
bank and I could say you have a really
good job but you're a woman and so get
your father to sign
I can't do that now it's illegal what
you're saying right now is you're you
have a really good job but you know a
really good business but I won't loan
you because you make ammunition you make
ammunition or you you deliver oil to
homes
so if I am I correct in that correct
thank you all right thank you I'm going
to go to representative Terry because I
think I missed your hand before and uh
you have a question for the witness yeah
uh there has been some discussion with
respect to uh dictating uh to to Banks
what they can do and what they can't do
do we not already to the best of your
knowledge already uh uh specify through
uh legislation through law uh certain
things that banks are prohibited in
doing for example redlining
yes that has happened and yet that gets
violated and it's been violated on
environmental criteria in California
thank you thank you
I'd just like to say we have five other
cards here so there's opportunity for
questions in the future
um I I think representative Sullivan you
had your hand up do you still have a
question
um so
I'm an economist I really believe in the
free market and so I'm trying to
understand how this is very counter to
the free market it seems to me if these
are truly bad Investments as you said or
bad loans you said the returns are lower
why why does the government need to be
involved here I mean is what's stopping
another bank from coming in and be like
we will focus on these issues that are
being ignored there'll be a great
opportunity for it it seems like it
seems to me that this is something the
flea market can handle and it's the ESG
strategy is bad then another bank should
be able to fill in that spot but I'm I'm
I generally get uncomfortable when the
government tries to throw mandates down
on people whether it's
good intentioned or not sometimes uh it
leads to some
concerning outcomes
I I understand and appreciate your uh
your consideration I'm also free market
oriented the the concern is that this
movement is so large and so overwhelming
that those other institutions are going
to be crowded out unless we say You must
stick with traditional criteria
follow
I I appreciate that and I that's a
perspective I I I'm curious if uh you
have faith that despite the size we've
seen is there is it basically is there
an argument here that there's like this
is almost like a collusion and so
therefore the government's warranted
yeah I'm thinking I'm thinking like
Microsoft when the government sued
Microsoft was that legitimate or did we
just let you know Apple come along and
disrupt the market the way they did well
the collusion argument is relevant there
are many attorney generals which are
currently bringing suit against ESG
movement for collusion okay thank you
ongoing effort representative spear
thank you
we've been talking you've been talking
about Investments at with coal companies
and gas companies and all that sort of
thing the law talks about individual
people
what are we dealing with here are we
dealing with trying to stop Banks from
investing in specific non-coal companies
are we talking about some private
citizen going into a bank and getting a
home mortgage
well this bank is focused on banking
activities in New Hampshire and so it
doesn't say that well it's a New
Hampshire RSA so it's without talking
but the if
if someone in who's a wildcat or in
Texas wants to come to New Hampshire for
a loan I I suppose they could I don't
think they would uh but uh the the point
is more directly relevant to what you're
talking about if you if you are looking
for a home loan you're looking for a car
loan you're looking for an appliance
loan you're looking for whatever or you
want to start a business and you are of
the right kind and not the wrong kind
that's what this bill is focused on
representative did you have a question I
just had just had a question
for the uh the committee what does ESG
um stand for
environmental social and governance
okay thank you
representative McLeary again further
question
um are you familiar with that case in
Texas where a county refused to do
businesses with uh banks that were using
ESG
no right sorry well just to clarify what
what happened is they ended up having to
pay billions of dollars more because
they refused to do a business with some
of these banks that were employing an
ESG method of financing thank you
all right thank you I think we'll call
it uh that was a lot of questioning
thank you for taking all those
um I think we we really
delved into that subject
uh I have um
the the Attorney General's office uh
Mary Stewart and they have a neutral
position on the bill
and ask for five minutes
hi I'm Mary Stewart from the Attorney
General's office consumer protection
Division and we are new we do have a
neutral position regarding this bill I
only have a comment on one provision
which is uh number two Roman numeral
Roman numeral two which states that any
financial institution who violates
paragraph one shall be guilty of an
unfair and deceptive business practice
under RSA 358 A2 which is our consumer
protection statute and I think as most
of you are familiar that
um
this statue deals exclusively with the
acts of financial institutions and
financial institutions are exempt under
the New Hampshire consumer protection
act so to the extent this bill
anticipates the Attorney General would
enforce we do not have any authority to
do that
as it's written and that's all I have
okay questions
representative spear do you have a
question I just didn't hear the last
sentence that you said so to the extent
that this bill anticipates the Attorney
General would enforce the statute we do
not have the authority to do that
can I ask a question I am a sponsor but
I this is a clarifying question is there
talking through my mouth
is there a similar provision in the
statutes that govern your Authority that
could could be substituted for that
um unfair or deceptive business
practices there are similar provision in
the statues like this so the bank
commissioner regulates and the acts of
financial institutions and they have
their own statute and I believe they are
also going to be testifying today
okay thank you any other questions
all right all set thank you very much
and next we'll call Christy Merrill of
uh the bankers Association
as for five minutes opposing the bill
good afternoon thank you Mr chair
um and honorable members of the House
Commerce Committee my name is Christy
Merrill I'm president of the New
Hampshire Bankers Association and with
me today is Ryan Hale vice president of
New Hampshire Bankers Association
um we represent 38 member banks and they
employ roughly 6 000 employees in the
state and we're here today in strong
opposition to house bill 227.
the intent of House Bill 227 appears to
prohibit Banks from engaging in
discriminatory practices when providing
Financial Services
we agree with the sponsor the bank
should not discriminate and we're
extremely concerned however that the
legislation of this nature will invite
frivolous lawsuits ultimately resulting
in increased lending costs which will be
felt by consumers at a time when
interest rates are rising
the bill uses vague and undefined terms
such as ordinary business practices and
objective Financial standards which will
subject Banks to increase scrutiny
anytime they turn someone away this then
places the burden on the bank to prove
that the decision was made for ordinary
business purposes
out of fear of litigation Banks could be
put in a position of approving loans
that they otherwise wouldn't resulting
in riskier loans poor credit quality
increased litigation and even more
regulatory burdens ultimately it will
encross increase the cost of Lending
additionally banks have in-house
expertise for certain sectors of the
economy in order to make safe and sound
and under in order to safely and soundly
underwrite loans under this proposal
Banks would again be forced to make
riskier loans due to a lack of expertise
out of fear of being accused of
discrimination not only will the subject
the bank to litigation but it would put
the bank in a difficult situation with
their Regulators since they are
regularly examined on safety and
soundness and I just want to emphasize
that point here on expertise so for
example we have a new member bank that
they specialize in agricultural loans
and so for example if a company in the
hospitality industry went before them
and said we'd like to work with you and
they said you know we really don't have
the expertise you know we focus on
agriculture under this legislation they
would be forced to work with that other
type of client even though they don't
have the ability to do so and they
choose not to do so
um basically this legislation turns the
idea of fair lending on its head
the general rule has always been that a
bank or other private company is free to
do business with the customers it
chooses as long as that choice doesn't
directly or indirectly disadvantage a
protected class such as race gender Etc
this law says there is no longer a
choice only if a person meets objective
Financial standards established in
advance which is not defined can a
person's request be denied
if ever if every instance a banking
customer is told no for particular
Financial Service and it's going to be
subject to scrutiny under New Hampshire
law it will create a tremendous burden
on financial institutions which could
impact decisions to do business in the
state is this really the culture that
policy makers want to cultivate for the
granite state so in looking at this
legislation we did share this with our
members and wanted to get some real
examples for you as to why this
legislation wouldn't work and so I have
just a few that I want to share with you
the first is regarding employee safety
so right now today if um if if a
customer comes in and they're making
threatening remarks to staff the bank
has the right to choose to not to do
business with that customer in order to
protect their employees in order to have
a certain culture that they want to
maintain and that could be true if
someone was if they were a racist if
they were all sorts of these negative
things under this proposal you know they
might think twice about choosing not to
do business with them out of fear of
discriminatory accusations
another example that was shared with us
is it's not clear if it takes into
consideration persons who have
mishandled their Accounts at previous
institutions so today what happens is
most banks report charge-offs what's
known as charge-offs for accounts that
have been closed with deficit balances
the new bank is then informed of unpaid
deficit balances but this language
requires the banks would still have to
allow that person to open the account
so that's an issue that I'd want to
raise with you all and then another
point I just want to make is just you
know we all know that there are
disgruntled customers and if a customer
is unhappy with a bank and they go out
in the community and they're
bad-mouthing the institution under this
law they would still be forced to
continue to provide them services
in addition to those examples you know
we we believe this bill is unnecessary
because banks are already subjected to
extensive regulation above and beyond
the laws which protect against
discrimination so this is a long list
but I think it's relative to the
discussion today so I just want to list
these these are all federal
laws and regulations that touch on
discrimination that Banks adhere to and
that that includes the community
reinvestment act the Fair Credit
Reporting Act Equal Credit Opportunity
Act the Fair Housing Act Equal Pay Act
Civil Rights Act Americans with
Disabilities Act and age discrimination
and Employment Act
additionally it appears that house bill
227 runs a foul of both the state and
the Federal Constitution
specifically in singling out Banks the
bill infringes on A bank's
constitutional right to free speech
stripping away its ability to make its
own Independent Business decisions
likewise the bill deprives Banks of
equal protections of the laws single out
banks in a manner that is specific to
only banks to our knowledge no other
business in New Hampshire is subjected
to such intrusive government controls
simply put if enacted this bill would
deprive Banks of fundamental
constitutional freedoms in a manner that
is unprecedented in our state
New Hampshire's economy is rightly the
Envy of most and banks are proud to be
part of that success and they take great
care in reviewing loan applications and
deposit accounts every year Our member
banks support our communities by lending
hundreds of millions of dollars to New
Hampshire businesses and Families
however household 227 will be
devastating to our New Hampshire
advantage and tie up Granite State Banks
and endless red tape and litigation
and this is a fundamental change in our
approach for our Live Free or Die state
which has historically sought to keep
businesses and individuals free from
unnecessary regulation
while we have seen Banks continue to
move here from other states so this
legislation could have a chilling effect
on that growth
New Hampshire Banks oppose
discrimination as should all businesses
and countless state and federal laws
already govern our conduct to ensure
fairness and transparency this
legislation is unnecessary and unworted
proposal that would pose serious and
negative consequences for all banks and
we would um recommend inexpediate to
legislate thank you
all right thank you Ryan Mr Hill do you
have anything to add
um
and could you submit a pink card yes I
absolutely will thank you
um yeah and we heard some comments about
the free market
um and uh the use of ESG and if you look
if you Google on um Vanguard last
December
um broke away from the Net Zero uh
because of the backlash they saw
um on this front so
um I can share with the committee an
article
um that was posted in December about
that so good
thank you and questions
oh and you have written testimony if you
just give it to the course we do have
written test that would be great I'm
just going to pick randomly okay uh
representative Sullivan thank you you
just sort of touched on it uh obviously
the question that you heard me ask about
the free market was
the pre-market should take care of it
sounds like you maybe have an example of
it I'd like you to maybe expand on that
because
um the sponsor's argument is that
there's a potential for a lot of
collusion going on which could really
stifle business that's the Crux of his
argument was I took it so uh maybe you
could expand on that is that something
you're seeing or are you seeing other
examples like this Vanguard one which
sounds interesting where the free market
seems to be doing its job
I don't know if you I don't have um I
just I think in response to the question
about
um if there's collusion going on
um you know we have a lot of confidence
in the free market and
um
I don't believe it is the case that
fossil fuel the fossil fuel industry is
not getting lending
um I do think that certain businesses
have their own set of mission and values
that may not align with that but I think
in our capitalist Society if one
institution says you know we don't want
to work with a fossil fuel company my
guess is there is another bank right
around the corner they'll be more than
happy to take their money so I know that
for some folks ESG is not popular but I
would simply say that customers always
have the right to vote with their feet
and so if a customer does not approve of
their financial institutions Mission
values their investment strategies they
always have the ability to take their
funds and go someplace else and so we're
happy about you know the the environment
in New Hampshire we have a competitive
Marketplace for the banking industry and
we do think that this bill May harm that
thank you
thank you representative Terry yes thank
you uh so we heard testimony uh and you
were present to hear this I believe
uh that the six major banks in the
United States have signed on to the U.N
environment program Finance initiative
which I understood to effectively mean
that they are adopting
um ESG policies and and goals
uh can you tell us
because you represent your member banks
here in New Hampshire if any um have
been approached
of to sign on to the initiative have any
signed on
and do any and the third part of the
question is do any of your member banks
uh have they adopted any sort of ESG
policies in Lending
um so I did I did not get a copy of that
I did hear that testimony
um you know I'm not an expert on this
Net Zero Global initiative of the six
Banks just going for my memory I think I
wrote them down but um Bank of America
they are a member of New Hampshire
Bankers JPMorgan Chase they have a
presence in New Hampshire they're a
member Wells Fargo we help them on some
legislative work they are not a member
but they do have a mortgage presence not
no banks here in the state with a branch
um I can't tell speak to whether or not
they have been approached what they've
signed on I can I can only see the
information that has been presented I
can tell you they are members whether or
not they are using ESG you know some of
our members are B Corps some of our
members do Embrace ESG some of the
Regulators encourage the banks to be
supportive of ESG what I can tell you is
based on previous legislation last year
when there was talk about social credit
scores and ESG scoring we asked our
members are you using ESG and social
credit scores for Lending in your Banks
and they told us no and we didn't know
what that was frankly until the bill was
introduced last year so that's the best
I can answer your question
so um the six banks have all established
targets which have either passed or are
coming due in the near future you do
have member banks here in New Hampshire
which whose parent corporations are
the Bank of America at the very least
and I can't remember the other
uh Morgan Stanley JP Morgan City so you
do have members but at this time you are
not aware of any of the uh member banks
in New Hampshire members of these one or
more of these six largest banks in the
United States who are who have adopted
and are applying ESG policies and scores
with respect to lending here in New
Hampshire
ESG scoring um definitely not we are not
aware of that ESG policies as I said
some have adopted ESG policies we are
not aware of any of our members using
ESG policies in their lending practices
thank you
uh representative Gibbs I think is next
thank you uh I just wanted to ask if uh
you could send your written testimony to
committee members by email
yeah we can do that thank you
representative Sullivan
uh thank you um so when representative
uh Bernardi was doing his testimony he
said that some of the smaller banks in
our state need to access
these Banks and my understanding of how
it works is that all banks have access
to the Federal Reserve but is that not
the case am I wrong with that like does
a small Bank maybe have to partner with
Bank of America to get Capital so
therefore would be potentially exposed
to various ESG programs so my
understanding is the same as yours all
banks have access to the Federal Reserve
through a master account which they can
apply for regarding small Banks and
relying on the big Banks the only thing
that I uh that I'm aware of that a small
Bank may do is they may partner out with
another institution on a loan if they
need if they don't have enough Capital
to to work with a particular customer
they may participate alone with another
institution but not aware of anything in
a few words so potentially there's a
theoretical
ability for Bank of America to enforce
it on a smaller Bank through that
channel that's like but it seems very
unlikely okay thank you
Representative Vincent thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
doesn't the BET don't the banks have the
right to deny without any explanation to
anybody
um I guess I'm not sure by your use of
the word right I don't know if they have
a right
um they don't
do not by law obligated to say hey we're
denying you for this reason or are they
I mean Banks they have customers just
like Bank just like any other company
has customers and they can choose not to
work with them for some of the reasons I
said right so if there's a a customer
that is insulting and puts their
employee safety at risk they can say no
um you know if someone if a bank chooses
chooses not to give someone a loan my
understanding is that that customer can
say hey why didn't I get the loan they
can ask that that question but um I'm
not sure if that answers your question
or not
thank you
a little set
anybody else
great thank you very much
you didn't call Emily yet
well thank you Commissioners normally
the first person I bring up
don't criticize money
no I'm just trying I'm playing
good good afternoon my name is Amelia
galduri I'm the bank commissioner for
the State of New Hampshire with me is uh
general counsel Seth saraki
um so we are neutral have no position
with regard to the underlying policy
considerations that have been discussed
in terms of political issues
um however
um we would take the position that this
bill is practically speaking probably
likely unenforceable as drafted due to
the numerous technical defects with it
or technical issues so or alternatively
doesn't really practically speaking
address the concerns that have been
brought out before the committee
um so first I would say that all of the
banks that were listed specifically in
testimony prior to now are not under the
jurisdiction of the New Hampshire
banking Department we regulate state
chart Banks state chart Credit Unions
state chart trust companies for example
we don't regulate nationally charred
Banks they wouldn't
have to comply with this law this law
falls under RSA 383-a which is under our
jurisdiction so
that's issue number one the second issue
is we don't have we have not received
any evidence that any of the
um
issues described to date
or that seem to be addressed by the
Plain language of the statute are
occurring we have not received any
complaints from consumers saying that
they were being denied
access to banking services for any of
the reasons that have been described
before the committee to date
um
further the language of this bill is
you it uses a lot of unclear terminology
to be candid so it talks about
seemingly credit denials so there are
there's a whole
um slew of federal laws that govern
uh when somebody has to be that when
somebody's denied credit they have to be
notified and there's disclosure rules
about that so this would seem to in
places directly conflict with those
federal laws and rules
and I and in cases where state laws
conflict with federal laws the federal
rules uh carried the day so
um those are just some of the technical
issues
um to the extent we we don't have any
evidence that
State chartered banks are running
the ESG scores I think that have been
discussed
um I think we did some research into
that last year and our research tended
to indicate that if somebody was pulling
an ESG score from some entity that
creates ESG scores that that would have
to be disclosed to the consumer so if a
consumer was being subject or credit
decisions were being made based on that
score the consumer would know about it
and we would have likely heard about it
um
so that's that um further just from a
practical standpoint
um
we would likely see an increase in
consumer complaints I would imagine as a
result of this law
and they would be very difficult and
time consuming for us to investigate and
would also increase correspondingly
increase the burden on the entity that's
complained about because our complaint
process is when we get a complaint we
have to run it to ground so we would be
requiring The Entity complained about to
respond to us
um we didn't get a fiscal note worksheet
request for this one I don't believe
it's a there's no physical note
associated with this
um but it would likely have some
physical impact on the banking
Department
um in addition to the entities that we
regulate
um
finally at the end the violation
language about the consumer protection
act so we do have our own unfair and
deceptive acts and practices that are
governed by the banking department and
um I would recommend that if this was
something you wanted the banking
Department to enforce that it
referenced those laws basically
um
and didn't miss anything okay
um so we're happy to answer any
questions
um that you may have
thank you very much
thank you
uh chair will call him representative
sellers
who's a supporter of the bill
got it
thank you Mr chair committee again and I
apologize last time I never introduced
myself representative sellers Grafton 18
I represent 10 southern towns in Grafton
approximately 17
000 residents I got the flutorial
anyways
um
one thing I like about this law it's
proactive instead of being reactive
and no law is going to be perfect coming
out the door so you may have to tweak it
if it's next year the year after but we
get something on the books I it will
protect the citizens of New Hampshire
and one thing that we all do we all do
banking
we all do it and we need it and let's go
back that goes back to the previous uh
build 225 where we're trying to keep
privacy and that's where crypto comes in
as well because you can do when you go
to back to crypto you can do direct
transactions you don't you skip the
banks all together so therefore
you know
the banks do have the power just like
the company I used to work for over a
year ago they came down after 20 years
working there they said show me your
papers that you've been vaccinated or
you're terminated
all right a four billion dollar company
said this to me after 20 years of
working for them all right now it was my
right to either show the papers or not
my point is big businesses have big
power over one simple individual like
any one of us here so I believe this
bill is actually being proactive will it
need an amendment or tweaked
yes maybe so but at least start getting
it in front of getting in front instead
of behind because the last thing we want
to do is not be able to go to the bank
and buy our next house at that point
there's no way I have 500 000 sitting in
my sitting uh sitting at my house right
now to say okay I'll buy that house and
cash here we go I have to go through the
bank and what happens if that bank also
goes and says well you know what that
next house has a
um oil furnace and we don't want to
really finance that or maybe we're going
to charge you an extra 0.1 percent
interest and you know who's going to
really know if they charge me a little
bit more interest or not from financing
that house there's a lot of unknowns we
know we don't know so what my point is
on this whole thing is I believe this
bill is actually proactive so
thank you great fair enough
representative Sullivan yeah I'm just
gonna close the same question I asked Mr
Bernardi which is
if you if you believe in the free market
which I do why is this bill needed
so again that you know there's no way I
don't like to put mandates on anybody
and you're right we're putting mandates
on a business which is an entity it's
not a citizen it's an entity but Banks
and also entities put mandates on us all
the time so I don't see anything wrong
with this
follow up for the question me and Claire
so
I think I read and it might be the bank
that the not the banking commission but
the lobbyist for the bank people uh just
talked about which is there is a bank I
think that is just targeting
agricultural industry now so like are
you saying that the free market does not
would not work in this case and so
therefore we can't have maybe a bank
that specializes in homes that only have
oil furnaces if they think that's a
great business decision or in this
example agriculture I mean it seems to
me the free market can find their little
niches in Banks and and I I'm struggling
to understand why this is needed so I go
back to the point of
will the bill will this bill need some
tweaking maybe so all right this might
not be perfect but it's a start
thank you
okay we're all set thank you very much
thank you chair
uh I have Glenn Perlo from the New
Hampshire trust Council
thank you very much uh
people have preceded me have said
everything that I would want to say so
I'm going to be fairly brief um I did
send in some written testimony uh last
evening I do have copies here if anyone
would like to review them
um
it's important uh I didn't have a chance
several weeks ago to introduce myself so
for those who don't know who the trust
council is uh the chair knows very well
because he's been involved in sort of
this Venture of modernizing New
Hampshire's trust industry and growing
it
um over now two decades
um so I'm president of trust Council and
I also serve as general counsel and
chief administrative officer of Jordan
Park Trust Company
um
you should know if you don't that
non-depository trust companies are State
Banks and while I love State Banks and
have lots of experience with them and
support everything that they have told
you because it all applies to the trust
companies as well I have to say that by
law we are not allowed to take deposits
and accept in very limited circumstances
make loans so the kind of overarching uh
political issues or ideological issues
going on are
um uh uh we're kind of not really in
that fight however uh bad bills can
often sweep in many unintended
consequences here
pardon the pun but literally our
business is built on trust many of us
have small selected groups of clients we
are in many ways more akin to choosing a
lawyer or a doctor or a dentist and so I
need to make that distinction because
the very way that we develop
relationships with our clients and
develop a mutual desire to work together
with clients would seem to violate the
ambiguous language in this bill
regarding non-financial decision making
and the other thing I would want to
emphasize is reputational risk is a real
thing the bank commissioner could tell
you and her team that when we are
determining whether we'll work with
somebody it's incredibly important
important for us to uh to mind that and
be careful with whom we do business
because our other clients
um can be affected reputationally and
ultimately we can be affected
reputationally and that's a huge thing
in the financial services sector because
you all and citizens want to trust us
and so uh I have detailed our concerns
with constitutional infirmities here the
only thing I'll interject in that regard
is it seems ironic if there is concern
about
larger forces
uh creating lack of opportunity or
cramming uh their view down that the
solution would be the government telling
private businesses how to do their
business outside of the sensible laws
that apply to us equally as depository
Banks and I will leave it there
great thank you
thank you uh one card left uh Lily Tang
Williams
foreign
I do feel the pain of the industry
banking industry is very heavily
regulated already but we all support
anti-discrimination
you cannot
discriminate anybody will go to your
bank either business owners or private
individual to say I want to get a bank
loan but I'm denied because I'm not in
the right industry because my political
beliefs because I did not buy into
United Nation or whatever climate change
agenda I mean the wrong industry oil gas
and fossil fuel there are a lot of
things that it's already in the law so
you cannot discriminate people plus as
somebody who come here
to believe in our U.S Constitution
people
are entitled to protection of private
property
when I look at you know they also that
when you talk about ESG
that's a very potentially dangerous
it's already been pushed down on us
you know ESG you'll know it's
environmental social governance
and
two major Global rating agencies include
the SP 500 they use ESG to read all
financial markets and capital investment
markets so if you are a red State like
Utah West Virginia because they are
heavy in oil and gas Industries so their
rating is low
even though there have lots of cash in
terms of mass and money they're great
but they cannot get a higher rate in
that affect how much cash investment
they're going to get in our in their
state maybe some will affect us in our
state
you know why because they have a power
and how are we going to help protect
people even though I understand you say
oh free market you need a free market to
work but discrimination
anti-discrimination is a government as a
job
I have seen social credit scores tied to
ESG related scoring in China
based on your political beliefs you
cannot go to even School you cannot get
a bank loan to buy a house you cannot
get a business loan to finance your
startup
and why are we talking about ESG
something even similar to China's social
security system if they can use that to
regulate what kind of business
Industries is going to get along it will
happen to our private citizens sooner
than you think we're gonna based on you
political beliefs
to decide if you are worthy to get loans
or not it's very dangerous I agree this
bill can be improved there are some
models and there's also lawsuit for All
State Traders about 30 States getting
together to sue some of those on reading
companies to say you're putting us in
this Advantage situation because we're
not you know in the right industry so
maybe this is the beginning point we can
discuss the issue we can talk about ESG
the more people talk about it the more
small business owners and bankers aware
of it
and the more you know then we want to
feel like we need to do something to
protect people's rights you know to free
speech is really come down to
business owners private property rights
they are entitled to get along has
nothing to do with their political
belief no matter with this realism or
not but also eventually then it's going
to regulate private citizens and so
that's that's just something come out of
my chest when I look at this bill to say
you know in principle are supported but
it can be improved thank you very much
thank you
see no questions thank you very much
oh my testimonies no question I would
love to have more questions about it
thank you thank you for your time today
okay
all right so that's it so we'll close
the public hearing
I don't know if it was a blue sheet or
not but okay we have one more Bill left
584.
keep the dude do a card
don't you can do it you can do it on the
way back you can do it
foreign
don't worry about it
we'll get you later we know where to
find you
I know we're running behind so I'm going
to keep my testimony fairly short but I
just want to say uh first time on this
side of the room and I didn't realize
how attractive our committee is so yeah
Lottery will get you everywhere
I'll talk louder
so for those of us that were on the this
committee last term uh we dealt with a
bill it was House Bill 1503
um
and uh the The Genius of the committee
and and I'll give credit to the chairman
for sure
um there was an idea to adopt
a new article from the uniform law
commission and uh the uniform law
commission is almost I think 100 years
old institution it's headquartered out
of Chicago
and its goal is to make uh
Commercial Code uniform between the
states
so a lot of uh commercial activity is
regulated by the states and to
facilitate interstate commerce it helps
if the states have similar or the same
statutes
and so a lot of our statutes and a lot
of the statutes this committee deals
with
our Uniform Commercial Code from the you
know the the universal law Commission
and so when we discussed digital assets
and that's a very big topic it includes
lots of things
but think about it this way
um in the past you could have a a
contract written
on a piece of paper and that people
would sign that contract and that
contract would either prove
agreement in a contract a mutual uh a
services for payment or something like
that or it could prove ownership like a
deed to a house
and so in our digital world that piece
of paper has become code that lives in
the
lives in a data structure somewhere on
the internet and the physical signature
is no longer a pen and paper but it's uh
become
uh cryptographic uh key that only you
own so a cryptographic key think about
it like a very very big password that's
impossible to guess so we're all
familiar with passwords but this is a
really big password
and that instead of your signature on a
piece of paper
that is your digital uh fingerprint
almost and so
the uniform law commission uh had a
draft that was almost complete it was in
the final stages they took I think over
two years developing it with this large
committee you can go online and look at
all their meeting minutes and see the
the um the process that was involved and
uh we got a permission they waived us
and said it was okay if we were the
first state to adopt it and we went a
little bit early
um
and we uh in the bill there was a
provision uh to report on changes that
we would have to update so that's what
this bill is 584
this is a minor uh
it's minor in the sense that it's a lot
of jot and tittles
but it does cover quite a few pages and
these are the final edits the red line
edits to article 12 that deals with
digital assets
uh and why is this important uh for one
this is one of the recommendations that
came out of the governor's
cryptocurrency digital asset commission
was that we should keep up with changes
in the UCC and that it was a good thing
that we adopted it
uh because it gives us rules of the road
a very Baseline set of rules
and a lot of it has to deal with custody
of digital assets so if I hand you a
piece of paper you can put it in a and I
say hold on to this and keep it safe you
can put it in a filing cabinet but if
it's a digital asset and I say hold on
to this and keep it safe there's a whole
set of rules and computer security
around uh custodying that asset and
because these digital assets are
becoming very valuable and an
increasingly larger part of our economy
it's important that there's rules around
you know one of the advantages of a
digital asset is you can self-custody it
so you can put it like like you would
put cash under a mattress there is a way
for you to self-custody that digital
asset but a lot of people don't feel
Savvy at computer savvy enough to do
that or they're they worry about the
long term you know keeping it so that
they could pass it on to their children
and their grandchildren that kind of
intergenerational wealth that people
want to build and so that they hand over
the custody to a third party to keep it
safe for them and that's what these
rules are generally about is uh who has
control of the asset and uh what are the
some of the basic guidelines for custing
the asset and you'll notice the uniform
law commission they didn't use the term
cryptocurrency digital asset nft or any
of these other fancy terms that we're
hearing they came up with a very generic
term called controllable electronic
records so when you see controllable
electronic record you think about
instead of a piece of paper it's
computer code and instead of a physical
signature it's a digital signature and
that uh someone can take control over
that digital record hand off that
control to someone else
and that's what these rules and
guidelines are about and this bill is
just cleaning up
the final draft that we had passed last
term and making it their
uh their current version of article 12.
so hopefully that
explains what we're doing here and I'm
happy to take questions
representative
thank you chair
we take my question who did you work
with um
what groups did you work with to
work on this bill so it's the uniform
law commission I believe there's someone
here from the uniform law commission
that's going to testify and they'll have
in-depth
more more in-depth knowledge about the
details so it you can go to uniform
walls.org you can search for the
commission that drafted this article and
you can look through all their minutes
and all the conversations they had about
tweaking it and changing it what about
this what about that and this is the
final Redline version between what we
passed last year and the current state
of the document okay thank you
okay Representative Vincent thank you
Miss chairman thanks for taking my
question so this is going to be transfer
of any electrical or any elect any type
of electronic
what like could it be Bitcoin transfers
too
yeah it could be that's exactly what it
is right well it's it's so the the term
that they use I guess it's a term of art
controllable electronic records it could
Encompass a lot of different things and
including Bitcoin
is
it could it could Encompass
because uh we've been having problems
with Bitcoin because we dropped our
wallet so to speak and it's lost and
that's going to be able to recover that
correct correct thank you very much
and just just to follow up on that a lot
of people worry about losing their
wallet and losing their Bitcoin forever
or whatever crypto we're talking about
I'm with you and they want someone who's
an expert at it to keep it safe for them
and that's what these rules are about
great thank you very much
oh God
representative Herbert
I'm I'm on the outside okay I just I
don't agree with anything that's going
on but uh the uh the electronic uh uh
code that you get which is your digital
signature that you're in custody of
whatever the assets are now this
so I would lose it before I left the
auditorium so that you go and give it to
your lawyer or somebody who's a trust
officer I'm I'm just would you believe
my question is who do you give it to
you're are you advising these people to
have a who do you give it
so that's an interesting question so
there are companies nationally and I
think even some locally and I'll just
give a plug to the New Hampshire Bankers
Association last fall I think it was
they had a cryptocurrency conference and
they had they had Banks and interested
parties from all over the state
discussing just that how could they get
into the the business if if their
customers are looking for it of costing
things so we're seeing that ecosystem I
think you used that word earlier today
it's growing and uh you know having
rules is important we saw the FTX
imploded because they were outside the
U.S jurisdiction they were in the
Bahamas and there was they weren't
following any of these guidelines so
that this is really a consumer
protection bill as as it is you know
attracting the industry to our state uh
hopefully can I have another uh I have
another question follow-up questions
um
so
I have a bunch of assets and I go to my
lawyer and can I put this into what I
would consider a trust and and it could
be any number of Assets in the same
trust and these my signature story or
signature is this
long long digital
Sig
but it but I can put everything in it
just like a regular trust I could do a
house and uh is that what I defer to Mr
perlow on that question but I think that
a trust can be set up to custody and I
believe they'd have to uh
they'd have to follow the guidelines of
U.S UCC article 12 to the extent that
they apply okay I'm thinking like I go
to my bank that's what yeah it's it's so
I don't want to go on too long because I
know we're late but uh the digital
um asset can represent something
physical it could or could represent uh
a share of stock in a company it could
represent the title to your house things
like that so
that's a quick question okay okay sure
represent a post
um so is it like a 401k you could put it
in your money in your Digital Credit
record in in your 401k or or it doesn't
have to be a specific bank or uh well I
think 401K is set up for tax purposes so
it would be a collection of assets
similar to a 401k but the the tax
implications are different so unless
it's a 401k for digital assets I mean
that that's as close as I can get to an
answer
so dinner
further questions you require so in your
401k you're you're put you can buy
stocks and everything in there would you
be able to do that with like
sort of like a 401k but it's a it's a
different kind of banking system
um it touches on that but it's it what
you're talking about is outside of what
this bill so the buying and selling of
digital assets that's not covered by
this this is really about who controls
them if you give them to a third party
what are their responsibilities if it's
a contract how does it get executed how
does an asset get perfected I think is a
term they use so it touches on that but
it's what you're buying and selling is
outside of this
okay thank you all right
so uh Aaron normally I would Aaron
normally I would have you up but would
you would you think we should have the
law commission come up first
okay
I know you would say that Tom
but I but I you know we're supposed to
respect you know officers
all right so Chuck Mooney from the
uniform law commission so I'll give my
short little story about the law
commission uh is when I first got on
this committee most of the bills would
be small little short pieces of bills
for little sections of the internet but
it right behind uh Rick and uh you guys
will see our lsrs back there and we have
whole books dedicated to UCC
and each UCC was representative of each
of the different elements of commercial
code and yes it is supposedly they were
all the same every state has passed it
rather than having a federal law we have
individual states past the same law and
here is our New Hampshire representative
good afternoon Chuck uh thank you my
name is Charles Mooney I'm a professor
of law Emeritus from the University of
Pennsylvania Law School I retired
recently after 36 years on the faculty
and after 14 years of law practice
much more important since November of
last year I've been a new Proud resident
of the State of New Hampshire
so I'm very very happy to be here and I
had my first
Driving Experience on the I-93 this
afternoon and
I won't say anymore
uh but I am very grateful for the
opportunity to say a few things about HB
584 I don't think I can match the
eloquence of Representative amen
uh but I maybe can answer a few of the
questions that have been raised but just
by way of a background the uniform law
commission is a private organization but
its Commissioners are all appointed by
States
and they adopt uniform laws whether it's
the uniform gifts to minors act or the
Uniform Commercial Code and although the
Uniform Commercial Code the UCC estate
law since the 1960s it's really been the
law of the land for commercial law and
that would include private transactions
including many consumer transactions
so the UCC governs transactions as
varies as sales and leases
of goods negotiable instruments Bank
collections funds transfers letters of
credit Investments securities
and secured transactions so if you buy
Goods on Amazon or use get a loan
secured by an automobile or have a
Securities account
the same law the UCC applies throughout
the United States
this uniformity and enactment by all
jurisdictions is very important as is
the substance of the law to to modernize
the law and so that's why as already
explained it's important for New
Hampshire to get the final version of
the of the text
enacted I will say that I was the
reporter the principal drafter of the
night 2022
uh amendments and I and I think it's
fair to say that these amendments bring
the UCC fully into the 21st century and
starting in 2019 a new committee was
formed to consider emerging Technologies
we met uh 18 times each time for two or
three days along with many meetings of
smaller groups and meetings of
constituencies and finally this past
spring and summer the two sponsors
uniform law commission and the American
law Institute adopted the final aversion
I was uh intrigued by the advance move
which I thought was very cool by New
Hampshire to adapt the not quite final
draft I grew up in Oklahoma where we
were known as the sooner States because
of the folks that we all thought maybe
they'd go the night before and start
staking their claims so it was named
after a bunch of crooks but
but this is this is what Sooners really
ought to be about as being on the front
and I gather we're going to hear a lot
more about that when it comes to the
primaries in
2024 being first as as well nearly every
article at the UCC is amended and
brought up today and these amendments
but the Crown Jewel
as the representative mentioned is is
article 12 on controllable electronic
records or cers
not too pithy but it's a type of digital
asset but one electronic record
just a record that's electronic but one
that can be subject to control
and that's analogous to possession of
this pen or physical property so digital
assets well
that's your emails that's
a music CD
it's an it's lots of things but we're
only talking about things that can
really be possessed so that they have a
the property like a quality that can be
controlled
yes it includes crypto like Bitcoin but
also digital assets that can be linked
or Tethered to other assets whether that
be uh valuable metals or right to access
a certain artwork like so-called
non-fungible tokens uh nfts more
important perhaps uh the blockchain
check not technology on which many of
these cers are based has many uses that
in the future may be very important in
the world of Finance
and so
what article 12 does is provide building
block property rules for these assets
like you've all read about FTX the
bankrupt custodian of customer
assets I I think probably we can all
agree that some form of important
regulation is needed for this industry
probably some State probably some
federal
but Regulators have a hard time
regulating something when they're
concerned about someone's property
if you don't have any property rules
that make some sense to govern that
property and we really don't have those
for Pure intangibles but through this
concept of control possession we have
this
so uh
I hope that's useful if you have any
further questions I'd be happy to answer
them but it's my honor to be here today
and I appreciate your attention
welcome to New Hampshire thank you very
much
you can ask me
does Bitcoin have a special State
because El Salvador adopted it as their
well actually it's very interesting
according to probably the majority of
the people that have looked at it
Bitcoin right now may be money
as defined in the UCC
but the UCC doesn't regulate money very
much it basically just talks about when
you're a good faith purchaser and an
asset possession an asset
but that's concerning for a variety of
reasons that can make convert things
into monetary obligations that we don't
intend so
the new amendments make it clear that
Bitcoin would not be money in the UCC
only a form of electronic money that's
adopted by a state
that did not previously exist
as this kind of controllable electronic
record so if the United States wants to
create a central bank digital currency
which we heard earlier yes it could do
so and so could El Salvador anyone else
but if it's a pre-existing
private
controllable electronic record
then like Bitcoin it could not ex post
be adopted by a state it could be
adopted by a state but it would not be
money as the UCC defines it
where they came from representative
thank you it's it's just a really minor
question I I love hearing about this
stuff but do you have a reference that
you could
provide like a website or a a book
anything so we could learn some more
absolutely we the the ulc has a a very
brief overview
and then a list of reasons why a state
should enact it although essentially New
Hampshire already has that the later
amendments are important because
technicality is important here but there
are no major policy changes and that
were that were made and then there's a
longer 11 page thing so that people who
want to study the UCC so you can go
right on their website
we've got those and we'll certainly make
them available to the committee John I
have a I have a commission a question
representative Herbert
I one of my concerns about crypto or any
any other uh currency
than the dollar is that in the
Constitution and this I think is very
important Congress has
been given a monopoly
over the money supply
and the Monopoly is is based upon the
fact that you can only pay to your taxes
in dollars
so my con my question is
I don't understand what the relationship
if these if we get these digital
currencies uh passed and accept it I
don't understand the relationship
uh or what the impact may be of uh the
Monopoly of the money supply if somebody
else is making a lot of money
uh digital or otherwise that is not
controlled then that has will have
impacts on the value of the dollar
itself
and and other things that concern me a
lot so I'm asking you yes what do you
think will be the impact if there is a
secondary currency
alongside the dollar
well
unless the federal government decides
it's going to be so there will not be
and I think it's a safe bet the federal
government will not
the fact that these things could be
treated by barter like we could trade
anything by barter and we don't stop
people from from doing that although the
the IRS certainly wants to know about
transactions that give rise to gains but
this doesn't affect what is legal tender
it doesn't affect anything that the FED
has to do
and
what is money for the UCC is basically
what is a monetary obligation so that we
know if a business is going to give a
security interest in its receivables
uh that's a right to payment
and so we want to make sure that's not
Bitcoin
but as for other purposes money is still
the same this does not affect that at
all
perfect answer thank you very much
thank you all right now
Tom so Aaron is a deputy
secretary in my former seat mate in the
house floor
and Tom Conley is our our state Guru
on UCC
thank you Mr chair that's exactly what I
was going to say and here is Tom
good afternoon everyone my name is Tom
Connolly and I run the UCC division for
the Secretary of State's office
um here speak in support of the bill the
uh certainly we're proud of the proud of
the fact that New Hampshire is the first
state to adopt article 12 and uh one of
the things I particularly like about the
bill is that it has no effect on the
operations it's Secretary of State's
office at all
um it's a free of government uh
involvement so far it's a response to
how digital assets are are handed or
handled in commercial transactions um it
is important that we adopt these these
technical amendments so that our our
language is consistent with what was
passed this year and I'm pretty certain
that a number of states will be joining
us as uh as adopters of the article 12
here in in the this that calendar year
they are they're taking no position
but yes they're in support of it
believe me if they had a problem they'd
let us know
so okay
everybody's comfortable now
so it is uh I can say
um that the fact that we we're number
one was it was due to Keith and Mr
Conley as the reason we we were able to
achieve to get over the the goal line
and be the first state so that's the
first thing I said
isn't law yet
and it wasn't
we had to solve a steel problem first
but all right so I I don't think we have
any questions so thank you for tuning in
but I'm sure you were
interested in the hearing itself
okay so I have no more cards
and I'm sorry Ryan that I didn't get you
to speak but you can send out a
Oh I thought it was but all of a sudden
it was appeared so I thought I missed
mystery card so okay
um otherwise I have
um the copy of what I my uh the liquor
commission's recommendation that I I
think is a good idea for
um the beer the liquor bill for the
license uh suspension and so I have a
copy here if everybody wants to have a
copy and um and otherwise I've scheduled
um I I myself uh really all I want to
come two days a week rather than three
days a week my wife is giving me hell
because I do the county and it's four
days a week and so what I did is um we
are going to go back again to uh
actually we're going to go downstairs
for Tuesday
and Tuesday we have
um
hearings and sub and subcommittees and
then Wednesday
we'll have uh
there's no session on Wednesday well I
won't I won't we have no exact session
for next week but we will be doing uh
this subcommittee on insurance bills
and the marijuana bill
um
because it's an early bill it's an early
Bill and uh so that is also scheduled
there's a subcommittee schedule for next
week
um and then
um otherwise otherwise
um
the will be will be all done with our
our hearings and so now it's just a
matter of getting the work done
I don't know if it's to another room
just another room sorry
okay
all right see you all